So I might plug some dates or like do
it,
do it.
And we're live.
Judd,
how are you buddy?
Yeah,
Judd apatow here,
dude.
You know susman real well.
Not only do I know your manager,
sussman judge Sussman when I was a kid,
I loved comedy.
So I got a job at the east side comedy
club that would just in Huntington on
long island.
This is about 83 84 he was the bartender
and he used to give me rides home
because I lived really far away and I
used to take a cab home and spend all
the money I made as a dishwasher on the
cab ride home.
Wow.
But I just wanted to be in the club near
comics.
Eddie Murphy was coming in.
It was crazy.
Uh,
and I swear to God,
this is no bs.
You have those people in your life that
you remember who were insanely kind and
cool.
And Jeff Sussman was like that.
As a,
as a young kid,
I was maybe 15 or 16.
I thought,
this is the greatest guy I've ever met.
He's so nice to me.
It gives me a ride home.
He's funny and I'm so glad,
uh,
that he's rich now.
He's been my manager since I was an open
miker.
Yeah,
he discovered him.
He is an open miker or in Boston.
Who are his first clients?
Uh,
Bob Nelson.
Yeah.
Bob Nelson at the east side comedy club.
Nothing funnier.
He used to do a show once a week and one
of the things he did is he would just
turn on the radio and scan through the
channels and do improv based on what was
on the radio.
So if it was elevated music,
he would do a dentist routine.
If it was heavy metal,
he would suddenly do like a heavy metal
guy.
And it was incredible.
Yeah,
that guy was huge at one point in time.
And then I think he blew a fuse or
something.
I think he's a very religious person now
and he's still performs in Branson.
It's a nice way of saying he blew a
fuse.
Depends on your view of things.
I guess maybe he's happier than all of
us.
That would be highly unlikely,
but maybe,
but God,
was he funny.
I mean truly.
It's funny as people get,
and then he built a thing on stage.
You have to imagine this.
He built like a wall on the stage and in
the wall he built two doors and he would
do all these bits.
We would come in and out of doors as
different people and then he did a thing
where he would like come out of the door
like one out of one door across the
stage and in the other door and then run
out that door again as a different
person.
So it looked like he was chasing himself
like it'd be like a gorilla chasing Bob,
but he would just change his body
language as he ran in and out of these
doors.
It was really creative.
No one has ever really done stuff like
that since even,
well,
something happened somewhere along the
line where carrot top owns props.
They don't,
no one does props anymore.
You remember when we first starting out
there was prop comics.
It was your genre.
There was Dennis Miller to do.
Perhaps when he started,
I heard that he used to put his lips
through a 45 record and I forgot what
the bid was and die.
I threw a couple of props.
First few times I went on stage.
I remember bringing a light and putting
it to my finger to make my finger look
like ets finger.
I can't quite remember what the bid was,
but that's how little material I had.
Isn't it funny though that that genre is
just sort of dissolved and it is funny
as hell I would to see carrot top in
Vegas.
I mean it's a ridiculous show.
I laughed my ass off.
I brought my whole family.
We really laughed hard.
I mean that is a funny genre of just
ridiculous,
stupid prop jokes,
carrot top case,
way more shit than he deserves.
He's very funny.
Oh no,
he's very silly.
Funny.
I mean I've always,
for the silly guys,
you know I love,
you know all the smart people in the
inventive people,
but this silly guy is also pretty great
and it's hard to write super silly jokes
and make people laugh out loud.
Like there's Comedians who are funny and
you're like,
oh,
that's funny.
And then there are people who actually
make you piss your pants.
And the one thing that job did,
it made me laugh was he was reds around
the crowded subway.
He's like giving the crowd shots,
he's handy out cups.
I'd really fast pouring shots and
they're spilling on people if he's ready
around giving people shots.
And then he like turned to somebody,
he's like,
okay,
give it to you,
you're pregnant.
But she clearly wasn't pregnant.
It was just a Chubby lady and it got
really awkward.
No,
that's always the best.
When you make that mistake,
are you allowed to just give people
shots?
Like what if you have an alcoholic but
they're just there.
They're sober,
but you are like so influential.
They go off fucking one drinks,
not going to hurt and then boom,
you just throw their life off track and
carrot top wanted it to happen.
Yeah.
You gotta be careful with that now.
Uh,
I certainly am not pouring booze for the
crowd,
but I appreciated it as someone
observing carrot top.
I appreciate that too.
But I would think as a performer you'd
have to be really concerned.
Too many people that you give them one
shot and they uh,
they vander Doug stamper from house of
cards.
Maybe carrot top is getting pre show
releases.
There can be a whole system
of how he knows who to give the shots
to.
He survives in Vegas too.
That does.
There's not a whole lot of people that
do that anymore.
Yeah,
there's like Penn and teller and they'd
been there forever.
Right.
But their show is a magic show.
And then there used to be like a lot of
residents they were doing stand up,
George Wallace,
Rita Rudner,
George George Wallace quit doing that,
right?
Yeah.
He did it for a long time and he had
enough at something,
something.
He explained to me how hard it is like
you have to,
you have to fill that room like every
night.
Villain rooms.
Let me say,
I said I'm going to who makes movies and
is terrified that people will show up.
Filling rooms scares me as well.
Like we have a movie,
the big sick,
it opens in New York and La this weekend
and then in two weeks it opens around
the country.
It's a kumail,
Nanjiani,
Holly Hunter and Ray Romano based on an
experience that happened to Kumail
Nanjiani when he met his wife and he
was,
he's from Pakistan and his parents
wanted him to have an arranged marriage,
but he fell in love with an American
woman and then she quickly got sick and
had to be put into a coma and it's this
really hilarious,
fascinating,
true story about him hanging out with
her parents while she's in a coma.
It's just a very unique story,
but it works great.
It's like 98% on rotten tomatoes.
It's like one of those gem movies that
comes around every like four or five
years.
What's it called?
It's called the big sick.
And so like right now I'm terrified,
you know,
will people go,
will you get off your ass for a great,
hilarious movie to go to a theater?
And it's the same thing with a stand up,
you know,
now that I'm doing some concerts,
I do you like track like how they're
selling.
It's a scary thing.
They go,
yeah,
don't worry about this city.
Uh,
they always sell late and then you look
at your numbers for months and no one
bought tickets.
And then like in the last two weeks they
sell out or do you just not tuned in at
all?
I try to tune into as little as I
possibly can.
Yeah.
Other than like doing the jokes
themselves,
doing the shows themselves,
you know,
family,
hobbies,
yes.
I don't tune in anymore.
I just feel like there's no reason to
have fuck you money if you don't say
fuck you.
So I'm supposed to be saying fuck you
right now.
Yeah.
But not really saying fuck you.
Just,
there's things to think about and
there's things to not think about.
Like there's like the things that like,
you don't have really any control over,
like whether or not people buy tickets
if fucking hilarious.
Yeah.
What are you worried about man?
You're super successful.
You've done some of the greatest movies
of all time,
but the things that always drive me is
the terror of things not working out.
You know?
That's what keeps me on my game is,
is to be scared.
That's why I'm going to tell your crowd
right now.
That's good because that's one of the
reasons why you're still good,
but just let me help you out,
dude.
You've,
you've,
you have to care.
Greatest comedy movies ever.
Just chill out.
No,
I can't chill out,
Joe.
I can't chill out.
That's why I'm going to tell people I'd
be at the Columbus Theater and
Providence Road at July 25th,
uh,
early with the plot and then a play
playhouse on July 23rd in Ridgefield,
Connecticut.
Then I met the,
the Wilbur in Boston.
That's one of the great,
the best place,
right?
Great Place.
Do you have a website where people could
read all these cause they're not going
to remember.
They're probably in their car right now.
They're like fucking the Wilburn boss
and July 24 of the wilbur.com.
I don't know.
See this is how I,
your website.
No website.
I've got nothing.
You don't have a website?
I don't I suppose to,
I thought websites.
My kids make fun of me.
If I even talk about the web.
Like if I say like kids.
Yeah,
let's find out on the of the worldwide
web.
They like dad.
No one calls it the worldwide web
anymore.
My daughter yelled at me the other day.
She said,
dad,
no one emails don't email me,
text me.
And she acted like I was like talking
about ham radio.
Yeah.
You might want to tell your kid to shut
the fuck up.
Exactly.
Like emails.
Everybody.
I email every,
what are you talking about?
I guess the kids don't,
the kids don't have attachments.
I think that they don't need it cause
there's no attachments.
Like it never has a pdf to send.
That's true.
And they don't spell your,
they don't care.
Every kid spells you are every fucking
thing there.
And what,
how old are your kids?
I have a 20 I have a nine and a seven
girls.
All,
yeah,
I'm old girls.
I'm 19 and 14 old girls.
Chaos,
chaos and they'll gang up on me and the
teen years are rough.
They were rough.
They turn on you a little bit.
The genetically,
I think they're supposed to like push
for their freedom and turn on you for a
while.
I also think they're so confused.
There's so many hormones raging to their
system that didn't exist just to like
there were a new person.
Like if you,
if you stop to think about how you are
when you're 11 and then how you are when
you're 15 it's only four years later and
you're a totally different human.
Yes.
I tell them that.
I say you're acting hormonal right now.
Can you please stop?
They can't help.
But we talk about the chemicals.
I have this book,
it's called a yes,
your teen is crazy.
And then whenever they give me a hard
time,
I just take it out and just reading it
in front of them.
But it is all about how their brain
isn't even cooked yet.
Right.
Your brain doesn't really cook til your
early twenties and you're impulse
control and everything is gone.
And that what you're supposed to do as a
parent is model,
same behavior.
And if they,
if they see you not lose your shit
thousands of times maybe that we'll
program them to handle problems as well,
but they are going to freak out a ton
and you shouldn't get that mad out of
them at them because they're not capable
of not freaking out.
But that is a hard advice.
It's hard advice.
And when you get down to the youngest
one,
like my,
my youngest is seven and I'm like,
don't you have your shit together yet?
Come on.
Everybody else is older than you.
Let's go,
let's go.
So they don't get a full shot.
But the younger kid always thinks
they're allowed to do with the older
kids.
Do.
So it gets scarier as,
as you have more kids,
right,
because they go,
well my older sister does that so aren't
and I allowed to do that now.
And you're like,
no,
you're seven.
Uh,
yeah.
It's,
it's a really weird time.
I think especially in California,
you know,
marijuana is basically legal.
It's a d it's a difficult debate to have
with kids.
What it is legal.
You can't even pull out the,
it's illegal card.
Right.
I'm not worried about marijuana.
And what age though would you not worry
about marijuana?
I'm not worried about it at any age.
If your seven year olds like,
you know what?
Someone handed me an edible.
Absolutely don't want my seven year old
or my nine year old to be smoking pot.
But I'm not worried about pot morgan
about alcohol.
Yes,
I'm worried about alcohol and I'm
worried about driving.
I'm worried about like teens drinking
and driving.
That's that.
That freaks me out.
Like her being with her friends as they
go to high school and that,
that freaks me out because kids just
don't know what their tolerances are.
They don't understand the effects of
alcohol on the body and your ability to
react.
That's curious.
It's all about uber or lyft.
I think that is one thing I noticed that
all the kids are,
there seems to be a lot less drunk
driving cause they all just uber.
Oh it's amazing if you can afford it,
but if you can't afford it,
I guess you're still screwed.
Yeah,
you are screwed if you can't afford it.
But it's pretty reasonable if you're
just moving around the general area.
Like if you're hopping around West
Hollywood and going from the store to
the Improv,
people do it all the time.
It's a couple of bucks.
It's not that big a deal and it's like
it's saves you all the worry and hassle
of being a drunk.
Are you a neurotic dad or a calm dad?
I tried to be as calm as I can.
You know,
certain amount of neurotic that's seeks
in seeps in every now and then,
but I try to be really calm.
Yeah.
The,
you know,
the thing is just everybody does it.
Everybody grows up and just haven't have
it.
Be Fun as much as possible.
I have a friend,
uh,
it older gentleman who's had a bunch of
kids.
He's always,
he's always said to me,
you know,
you got to let him go through it.
You know,
they're going to good.
They're going to do the drugs.
It's fine.
They get through it.
They figure it out.
You know,
you got,
they're going to have sex.
You can't stop it.
You get to let them go through it.
They'll,
they'll figure it is your friend.
The dude from the big Lebowski is,
it's a,
it's literally a John Goodman.
I sat down with the dude was,
uh,
what's his face?
Not John Goodman,
the other guy.
What's his name?
Jeff.
Uh,
Fuck.
Oh,
Jeff Bridges.
Yeah.
He's a dude.
Yo,
he's the dude in the movie,
right?
Yeah.
I saw it the other day.
I haven't seen it in years.
I was fucking crying,
laughing.
Oh,
it's a good way.
It used to be my movie,
my litmus test for whether or not I
could talk to you.
Like,
how do you feel about the Bagel basket
booster?
Shit,
I got to go.
Yes,
we did an episode of freaks and geeks
where he shows John Daly's character
saying we're shows a girl of the jerk
and she hates it and,
and he breaks up with a cheerleader at
school cause she hates the jerk.
Good for him.
I said with a girl in high school where
she hated n e t and I and that was a
rough one to where it rough on to
survive back then.
Yeah.
There's certain music and there's
certain movies that you're just not
allowed to like or hate.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well that's a funny thing.
My wife and I is,
we violently disagree on a lot of that
stuff.
We don't have like one or two violently.
Yeah,
there's,
there's one or two like the main things
that mean the most to me in the world
where my wife's like I can't,
I can't,
I don't like it at all.
And then stuff that she likes it,
I go,
I hate that more than anything.
I think that's good.
I think it's good,
especially with your spouse to have like
very few interests in common.
I think all those people that do
everything together,
a fucking Weirdos man,
they always freak me out.
That it,
that is interesting.
Yeah.
Cause it's a,
it's like stand up.
My wife,
I met her when I wasn't doing stand up.
I did stand up from the time I was 17
until I was 24.
I met my wife when I was 28 or 29 so she
didn't know anything about staying up
until three years ago when I started
doing it again.
Yeah.
What,
what caused you to do that?
I remember when you started coming
around,
everybody was like look at Judd and was
doing,
it's funny,
I,
I uh,
when I stopped when I was 24,
I was pretty burnt out.
So that was 92 and I was getting a lot
of writing work.
The Ben Stiller show got picked up,
this sketch show we did for Fox and that
kept me busy and I was making,
you know,
a lot of money compared to the $500 a
week I was making,
doing standup on the road.
And I thought,
well,
this is the universe saying you don't
need to do stand up and you should stop.
Maybe your friends are funnier than you.
And I'm living with Sandler and I'm
hanging out with opening up for Jim
Carrey and it's,
it's daunting.
You know,
it's like trying to start a band and
your friend is John Lennon.
He just feel like
it would be weird to not feel like a
dick.
I was cocky with Jim Carrey and oh yeah,
the funnier than this guy.
I mean,
I'm a sane human being.
I know,
I know what's happening.
Um,
and I was also a little bored of it
because I was so obsessed since I,
since I was 10 and you know,
I did funny people,
I did a little standup to write jokes
for funny people.
So I was writing jokes but it was for
Adam's character.
And then I started hanging out with Amy
Schumer working on train wreck and she
would come back from these tours and I
just got jealous.
I thought,
that sounds like the most fun thing.
And then one night I said to her,
I'm going to go up tonight just to make
you laugh just to,
so you could see what it was like when I
did stand up.
And then I told a couple of stories.
I had told her on talk shows and I knew
would go okay.
And Amy was very excited hoping I was
going to bomb.
Like she was thought this would be this
funny thing.
Judd bombs at the comedy cellar and I
did pretty good just cause it's stories.
I know work okay.
And then the common,
he's probably said,
hey,
anytime you want to come back,
just pop in,
we'll put you up.
Now.
No one ever said that when I was a comic
because it was hard to get stage time.
And I thought,
wait a second,
I'm getting treated like somebody who,
who gets the show up and go on stage.
I have to take advantage of this.
And I went on every night,
the entire shoot of train wreck.
No matter what time we finished
shooting,
I would drive straight to the comedy
cellar.
Wow.
And I had the best time.
And then I came back to la and started
doing the Improv and the comedy store in
Largo and,
and then I would put these benefits
together at Largo once a month.
And,
and to me that was the most fun because
I could book a show and get like
channeling to come and Randy Newman or
you know,
Aziz and Fiona apple and we did them all
his benefits and I always liked
producing things like that.
And then slowly my act got to the point
where I thought,
oh,
I'm,
you know,
I deserve to be here.
This isn't some freak show.
Well,
you know the difference between someone
who writes for television and movies
and,
and the different stream that,
and a lot of stand ups is when you're
making a living writing and producing
and directing and doing all,
you're disciplined you right?
Yes,
actually right.
You have notes,
you have books you have like you're
opening up your binder,
you're going over your stuff.
So comics don't do that.
I remember when I started,
I was opening for Larry Miller,
one of the legendary comedians and he,
he would have these incredible,
but some of them were like 10 minutes
long.
He had a great bit about,
uh,
about drinking.
It's one of the best standard bits of
all time.
And he had a bit about Thanksgiving and
a skiing and they were all like 10
minutes and they would get funnier and
funnier.
And one day he said to me,
you know,
this is a job.
You got to sit down every day,
write jokes.
You don't just go to the mall and watch
a movie every day.
Like if you sat down for two hours at a
desk and treated this like it was a job
that deserves your respect,
you'll be a hundred times better than
everybody else.
And I did listen to his advice at the
time,
but I do now,
like now I sit down to write it up.
Yeah.
I do show up with like notes.
You're like one of the rare guys at the
comedy store,
he'll show up but notes.
Exactly.
I know nobody has notes.
If it has like a little like a business
card with three bullet points on it and
I'm a little more of the,
you know,
the shandling tons and tons of paper
until you're drowning and confused
shandling,
you know,
that's a sad one,
man.
Fun Dude that was oh the best.
And I'm doing a documentary about him
now for Hbo.
And so the most fun part about it is he
always went to the comedy magic club and
did stand up even in eras where you
didn't know he was doing it.
That's where I met him at the comedy
Magic Club.
And how was it?
I was great.
Yeah,
I mean it was like for me,
I was a huge fan of Larry Sanders show
and Larry Sanders show a,
that's where Paul Simms got start,
a producer of news radio.
And so when I,
you know,
when I saw him I was like,
it was one of those ones like,
oh wow,
that's a,
that's actually garry shandling right
there,
right there with judd apatow's right
there.
It's a weird one.
And He,
and you know the comedy magical,
they tape every show since the 80s they
have every show taped.
And I said,
can you give me the last 50 sets that
Gary did?
The comedy Magic Club.
And this is,
you know,
from the last few years.
And no one's ever seen any of these
jokes except that people at those shows,
he didn't do him on TV.
He didn't do them on talk shows.
There was no special,
some of the funniest jokes you've ever
heard.
Just him,
you know,
working on the craft.
How about going around being so funny.
Yeah,
but he,
he did a lot of notes.
He was a,
his discipline guy.
He was in the 70s he wrote so many
jokes.
I found these binders,
hundreds and hundreds of jokes in every
loose leaf binder.
Like a guy sitting at a desk all day
just crafting like two sentence perfect
jokes.
Yeah,
but there's like the balance,
right?
There's that.
There's crafting the perfect jokes and
then there's just being able to be loose
and fun and hilarious.
Well,
he also used to go on stage with a
justice setup and he wouldn't know the
punchline and he would say the setup and
hope the punchline came,
which is pretty wild.
He,
um,
you know,
one of the,
one of the great things about doing a
documentary as you get to ask people for
footage,
so Seinfeld gave me,
uh,
the dailies for Comedians in cars
getting coffee when he interviewed Gary.
And then the people who made the movie
comedian about Seinfeld gave me all the
dailies of a sequence that they only use
10 seconds of in the documentary,
which was Gary and Jerry going to the
comedy magic club and doing sets.
And also there that night as Neil and
Chris Rock and there's 12 tapes.
It's all their performances and then
their entire conversation for three
hours hanging out backstage.
And it is unbelievable the conversation,
how funny it is.
And,
uh,
there's a moment where Chris rock is
doing the joke about how Nelson Mandela
got divorced,
that even Nelson Mandela,
after decades of being in prison,
he could survive that,
but he couldn't survive getting out and
being married and gets divorced
immediately.
I forgot how he worded it,
but there's a shot of shandling alone in
a green room watching rock do this bit.
And as he's doing it,
Gary's I saying what he,
what he's like,
he's guessing what the bit is as rock
saying it,
but in awe of Chris Rock and it's a,
it's a really beautiful moment and
that's what the best part of doing in
this documentary is it just finding
little magical moments that no one would
ever see if you didn't dig deep.
What made you decide to do this?
And we did a memorial for Gary when he
died at the Wilshire Evil Theater and
like a thousand people showed up and I
made about five mini documentaries about
gary to show in between the speakers and
I thought,
oh,
this is a documentary.
I should just expand this.
And now it's like,
now it's like the Oj doc of Gary.
It's a big,
long epic documentary.
I think people don't realize how good
the Larry Sanders show us.
Yeah.
Like people forgot,
you know,
if he'd go back and watch it again,
that was a revolutionary show and it was
on the air.
It really was.
Well,
people don't go backwards.
Like my kids don't go backwards digging
that far.
Like to them,
you know,
looking backwards means I'll watch all
of parks and rec,
right.
They're not taking into the 90s.
Uh,
they go to 2015 and people forget that
when the Larry Sanders show came on the
air,
you know,
the shows on Hbo,
it was like a first and 10 are not
necessarily the news or dream on,
you know,
Gary was the first show on hbo that made
Hbo go,
Oh,
this is what hbo should be.
We should be the quality,
uh,
network with all,
with this kind of groundbreaking
television.
And,
uh,
you know,
Gary was a guy who got offered all the
talk shows.
He got offered to replace,
um,
he was hosting the tonight show for
Johnny.
Uh,
him and Leno would,
would,
uh,
take turns doing it and he decided he'd
rather satirize it then do it,
you know,
and he wanted to explore the people and
not be a talk show hosts.
He wanted to show like the world of ego
that is not just talk to us but just
show business.
He was fascinated with people's need for
attention,
his own need for attention,
his own vanity and narcissism.
And he wanted to explore that and,
and satirize how we just want to be
liked so badly.
Like what we do to be liked,
which prevents us from actually feeling
love cause we're so obsessed with
approval.
Do you talk to Jay?
Do you,
are you friends with Jay Leno?
Yeah,
Jane and I were talking about,
um,
what it was like to host the tonight
show and how much more funny has now
doing comedians and cars are not
comedians and cars.
A Jay Leno's garage.
Yes.
And because that's what he really loves
you and he really loves cars and he gets
to be himself while he's doing this.
He doesn't have to have people on it.
He doesn't want,
like he just has people want to talk to
them about cars and stuff and has comics
on and all kinds of people on.
But you know,
when he was talking about like having
that choice,
like you would have people on that,
you didn't give a shit about it and you
had to talk to them.
And for Jay that was most everybody
because he loves certain things,
but he doesn't love sports.
He's not a massive movie Fan.
But you got him going on the things he
cares about like cars.
He's fascinated.
But that I think was some of the fun of
watching the tonight show,
really interviewing a young actress and
you know,
he doesn't care at all.
And how is he going to make it abusing
for himself at the audience.
Did you see the hex bit that Hicks did
about Jay interviewing joy lawrence and
he blows his brains out and it forms the
NBC peacock or the wall.
I mean,
I always felt that could loads.
I always thought that was very unfair.
The Hicks and the Andy kindler
criticisms of Leno.
Leno was,
you know,
and as you know,
what are the great standups of all time?
I mean in a club you'd see letter in the
eighties nobody touches it.
He was just,
it was amazing fun guy and still,
I saw him recently at the abrupt still
is and you know,
he made a call to,
you know,
to be America's host,
beat everyone for forever.
Forever was proven completely correct.
But there was this idea that it was a
betrayal of his club persona that some
comedians were so mad about.
And I don't know how you could be mad at
anybody for deciding how to run their
show because you know,
as we've seen with other people,
sometimes snarky guy runs out of gas in
two years and you know,
jay found the space that was comfortable
for him and God was he nice to me every
time I was there.
He's a great guy and always super funny
when I was on the show and Super Nice
would put me on when I wasn't doing
stand up just as a director just because
he liked me as a person.
Um,
and uh,
and a really a good class guy and in the
Shanley documentary,
fascinating describing his observations
of Gary,
his observations about talk shows,
uh,
I mean,
what a ride he went on.
Did that world of being a talk show
host.
There's not a lot of wiggle room,
especially back then,
you know,
as opposed to now.
Now with the Internet,
I think a lot of like subject matter and
a lot of language has opened up more.
You can kind of get it.
Like if you see like what's going on now
with,
uh,
with Seth Meyers or you know,
any of the other late night talk show
hosts,
they have much more relic look at core
bear gold bear rather coburn said that,
you know,
Donald Trump,
the president uses Putin.
Like he uses his mat,
like coop Putin uses his mouth as a cock
holster.
Like he said that on television with the
phrase cockles guess they beeped it out.
Do you not aware of that?
I'm not,
that's,
it was in the chrome,
the long rant.
And it was really hilarious because
trump,
uh,
came back and it said a bunch of,
think about cold bear and being
tasteless and talentless and being a
loser and all these different things.
Yeah.
And cold bear came back again.
He goes,
Donald Trump,
he goes,
I thought if there was one thing you
understood its shell business.
And he goes,
you responded.
He goes,
I win.
You don't understand.
Oh fuck.
And it was,
it was really fucking cool.
Well,
trump can't help but respond.
Yeah.
He has no ability to go.
It demeans me to acknowledge you exist.
He doesn't understand that.
And so I think these easily baited into
any of those situations,
which is,
I think a little is what scares people
because you think if Cole bear can paid
him.
What about other countries and very
serious situations?
What,
what bates him into action that he
shouldn't
take?
Well,
he blocks people on twitter.
Yeah.
He's the fucking president.
People are trying to,
they're trying to figure out like is
that like a first amendment issue?
Like was it,
am I allowed to communicate with the
president directly through twitter?
Well now I can't cause he blocks me.
Is He allowed to block people?
So there's people that are considering
lawsuits right
now.
Does Donald Trump understand you should
just be muting people.
Just mute them.
Donald,
you don't have to block now.
He wants him to know what I'm going to
know Magda.
I like blocking people.
I love block and people in the second I
see anything I blocked somebody who even
if they say,
what am I?
Movies was just okay.
I didn't know have to be that main boom.
I'll never see you again.
Wow.
Really?
If somebody says that was who,
that was pretty good,
I'll block them.
Block them on almost a compliment.
Wow.
Almost looks weird.
Underhanded stuff.
You're not kissing my ass pretty hard.
You're gone.
That's,
that's my twitter theory online.
You know,
I don't even need you to call me a Jew.
That's the funny thing is that when
people say nasty things on twitter,
they always start sounding like they
make sense,
but then bail at the end,
you know,
so they'll just be like,
give,
give the president a chance.
You know,
[inaudible] was duly elected by the
American people and go jump in and
nothing.
It's always like the,
to beat the,
the,
Oh,
they're saying you,
it sounds sane and then it always lands
on jumping in oven.
Did you stop exactly that.
Go well.
Do you take a lot of heat for
criticizing the President [inaudible]
Jones?
I don't.
It's pretty soon.
I mean,
I don't think I'm saying anything that
anyone else's and saying because I have
a simple theory about all this stuff,
which is I don't think rich people want
you to be rich.
I think that people are trying to be
told that rich people really can handle
everything.
And if you let the rich people have all
the money that they're just going to
figure it all out.
And in fact,
last night was an interesting night
because of Donald Trump said he doesn't
want poor people in charge of the
economy and what,
what he said that,
yeah,
he said he goes,
I want rich people.
But it's what he's not understanding is
there are public servants who have not
made the choice to be billionaires who
actually understand the economic
theories better than,
you know,
the head of Walmart or something that
just because you were able to figure out
how to sell m and ms,
it doesn't mean you can run the economy.
That there are people that they don't
want to be rich,
they want to help other people.
And they are a very smart about ways to
help the government work well.
And you know,
that's like saying a Martin Luther
King's that loser because he wasn't
rich.
He's not smart and this only rich people
know how to do things.
I find so offensive.
And I'm very surprised that people who
aren't billionaires aren't more offended
at the contempt that they're held in.
Cause you could disagree on economic
theory.
You could say,
oh,
I believe in trickle down economics,
or I don't believe in trickle down
economics,
but this is a government that thinks if
you're not a billionaire,
you're an idiot.
I mean,
I think he thinks that I,
you said it last night,
it's just not easy.
It's a literally a speech,
which is,
would you want poor people in charge of
the economy?
Which is the argument for having like
the head of Goldman Sachs in charge of
the economy,
but yet,
what is a poor person?
How is he defining it?
Is he defining it as an idiot failure or
someone who hasn't decided to milk,
uh,
this world for as much money as they can
get out of it?
Some people are happy to make a
comfortable living and try to be giving
to other people and they can be very
helpful.
Uh,
being part of our government,
you don't have to be the head of Goldman
Sachs,
uh,
to be,
someone who can change people's lives
for the better.
He thinks you just get the head and neck
Exxon,
the had a Goldman Sachs,
but sometimes you don't want the head of
Exxon.
You want someone that's thought about
international relations their entire
lives and maybe they've always made 200
grand a year.
That doesn't,
that's not poor.
Like what the,
it depends on what your,
how you define that core
and how he defines poor.
Yeah.
I mean when you say you don't want to
pour person running the economy,
I think one argument for that would be
you don't want anybody who wants radical
redistribution of wealth.
One article,
one Om argument while that rather it
would be someone who says like what we
need to do is we need to figure out who
the richest people in the world that own
90% of the money and then just take that
money and distributed to everyone else.
Like this is,
there's some pretty radical arguments
from Portland.
Well,
I don't think he's saying that.
I say I think he equates poor with
idiot.
He wasn't saying,
I don't want the,
you know,
a Bernie Sanders type.
He was saying,
I want,
he considers like the head of Goldman
Sachs to be the smartest man in the
world,
where there are people who,
who don't seek to make that much money,
who are very smart and certainly capable
of doing things.
I think he sees people who are not the
heads of industry as being incapable of
being in charge of aspects of the
government.
Right?
Because that's his world because this
world is the world of super rich people.
And if you're not a super rich person,
you're a loser.
Well,
that's the thing.
It's all a winner,
loser economy,
which I find fascinating because he is
basically calling most of the world the
loser in his world.
And so yeah,
you could debate.
I mean,
I always think most people don't even
understand most of what they talk about
with politics.
Like when you talk about wealth
redistribution that a lot of people are
fisheries,
but they actually don't know anything
about,
uh,
they have no information that the,
no one's read a book about it.
And it has very few,
very few.
I mean literally less than 1% and 1% are
arguing about on a regular basis.
They've seen a few clips on Fox News and
they have this idea in their head of
what it is exactly.
And I think that's what's wrong with our
country is no one knows anything about
anything on either side.
Like people don't know,
uh,
you know,
deeply about,
uh,
the environment.
There's very few people who sit down and
read the study.
Very few people right now are going to
read that healthcare bill that is before
the Senate.
Right?
Like how many people do you think,
what percentage of the country think is
going to sit down and read any part of
it?
Less than one 10th of 1% and destroy
their lives if they get sick and they
don't have coverage and who knows,
maybe it's perfect and we don't
understand it,
but people won't bother to know anything
about it.
Warming.
Yeah.
You talk to the average person on the
right or the average person on the left
about global warming,
and you will see like it's really
strange how you see these ideologically
driven ideas that they have in their
head about what global warming is,
what causes it.
And you can almost guess based on their
reaction to it,
whether they're republican or whether
they're liberal.
Yes.
And people,
you know,
obviously everyone talks about this,
but people have chosen the side.
And so now anything that that side does,
people are okay with it.
Yeah.
And so we suddenly were so soft on
Russia and then all these,
you know,
the being a republican used to be so
about the evil empire and on a dime,
it's like people like
Russia.
Well,
look what they did with Wiki leaks.
Wiki leaks,
everyone's turned on Wiki leaks.
Wiki leaks used to be the champion of
information.
He's to be,
these are the people that are trying to
let you know all the shit that's going
on behind the scenes.
We're finding out all these secret
emails,
we're sharing them with the world.
We're,
we're,
we have a media dumped,
there were dumping everything.
Now it's Wiki leaks is Putin's puppet
and wikileaks is working for Putin.
The left is turned on.
Wiki leaks was quite fascinating.
Well both sides we'll switch based on
what serves them in the moment.
Yeah.
But it's dark man.
It's really weird when you see,
when you see it so obvious and it's so
flippant,
like there's not a lot of thought put
into this.
Like you're talking about someone like
Julian the size.
I'm not a giant Julian assange fan as a
human being,
but I think what he's done is pretty
goddamn courageous and he's taken a huge
hit for it.
I mean,
he's been stuck in this embassy in
London forever.
If he leaves,
he will immediately be arrested and who
knows what's going to happen to them if
that happens.
So this is,
and this guy is still out there trying
to distribute information.
Well it's about is it's selective,
you know,
if a guy like that is just,
I mean obviously the issues are,
is he putting people's lives at risk
with w mega dumps,
which reveal sources and things like
that.
But also is he,
is he manipulated to release things to
serve a different,
you know,
political.
Is he doing it on purpose in one way or
the other?
Is the stuff on the Republicans?
You know,
if we had all the,
all the emails of the Republican's
planning the trump campaign,
uh,
we'd have a whole nother story to tell.
Now,
is it impossible to get their emails?
Do they just have the best computers in
the world and there's no way to get
their emails or it depends on what the
story is.
Like,
you know,
that they believe,
I mean,
it's,
it's so hard to figure out what happened
here,
but that seth rich guy,
according to Kim Dotcom and according to
Julian assange,
he leaked,
he was a Bernie Sanders supporter.
He worked for the DNC.
He leaked some of the information that
showed that the DNC was colluding and
what they were trying to do was a con.
They were conspiring to keep Bernie
Sanders from winning the primary.
And it proved to be true that that they
actually did do that.
And Julian Assange,
uh,
was setting after that guy got shot,
that somehow or another,
he was alluding to that if you work with
us,
there are consequences.
So you had someone who was a,
a renegade inside the DNC who released
that dump.
You don't have anybody like that on the
Republican side.
It doesn't mean that the wikileaks is
corrupt.
It just means that no one on the
republican side has done that.
Only one guy,
according to them,
I don't know if it's true,
they,
some people say Russia did it,
but according to Julian assange and
according to Kim Dotcom was apparently
somehow or another involved at least
part of it had to do with this seth rich
guy.
That doesn't mean that they're like
trying to exclusively released stuff
than makes Democrats like bad.
It just means no one's done it on the
republican side.
Just because the information doesn't
exist,
it doesn't mean there's some sort of
collusion.
Well,
that's the,
I guess the mystery of it.
I don't even know anything about the
seth rich case.
What,
what does that,
cause I know people are mad about us.
That guy that was,
he worked for the DNC and he was
murdered outside of his apartment at
four o'clock in the morning.
They said it was a robbery,
but he,
there's a giant conspiracy theory to
attach to it,
but I'm just going to relay the facts.
His wallet was left,
his phone was left,
his watch was left,
his valuables,
that he might have been robbed of his
monies.
All that stuff was there.
So he's just murdered and they never
found who killed him.
And then immediately Julian assange was
alluding to the idea that this guy was
helping them and that he was murdered
because that,
and that has been hotly
contested.
And of course,
uh,
the Fox News narrative has like gotten,
like Sean Hannity has made a big deal
out of it saying that he said,
we're going to get to the bottom of
this,
ladies and gentlemen,
which makes me more suspicious and it's
not true,
but it is a possibility that he was one
of the people that was releasing
information.
I would imagine if you worked for the
DNC,
especially if you were a Bernie Sanders
supporter and you saw what they were
doing,
what they were doing is essentially they
were,
they were hijacking the democratic
process from inside,
from the Democratic Party.
Yeah.
And if you were a Bernie sanders
supporter,
it would be horrifying and it would
really piss you off.
And especially if you're someone who's
idealistic,
you've got this idea of like what the
future could be under Bernie Sanders and
you realize your own party is fucking
him in the ass.
And so,
uh,
I don't know how much he released or if
he released or if he was only one part
of it or Russia was a part of it as
well.
And hacking into the DNC.
But the bottom line at the end of the
day is it exposed corruption.
I mean that's really what it was.
There's absolute clear corruption in the
DNC and everybody got away with it.
The woman who was in charge,
she went and left and went immediately
to work for Hillary's campaign.
And you know,
it's,
it wasn't good stuff.
It was all bad no matter what.
No matter who really released it.
It just showed you how gross the system
is.
Yeah.
To the core.
All the way around.
On both sides.
Cause I'm not a big conspiracy theorist.
I should be.
But why should you be?
I guess that there's always more going
on than we think.
But I also think that most people are
too dumb to not get caught almost every
single time.
Yeah.
You say that,
but there's a lot of shit that happens
where people do get caught eventually
and you realize,
oh,
like how long were you guys running
this?
What's your favorite conspiracy theory
that turned out to be true?
It's hard to say whether it turned out
to be true,
but JFK is the biggest one.
And where did you land on that?
I landed on that.
It's very possible,
very possible that Lee Harvey Oswald was
involved.
It's very possible that other people
involved too.
It's very possible that he shot at
Kennedy and other people shot at Kennedy
at the same time that and then he was a
patsy and he was put like,
he was obviously involved in a lot of
intelligence agency shenanigans.
He went to Russia,
he married a Russian woman,
came back to the United States.
He had been involved in all sorts of
communists,
propaganda shit.
He was definitely not like an above
ground guy.
He was a shady dude and it's entirely
possible that he was one person out of a
plot to kill the president and they put
it all on him and they had Jack Ruby
shoot him.
But everybody goes black and white on
that.
You either go Lee Harvey Oswald acted
alone or you go,
he was innocent and the CIA had him
assassinated because he was trying to
get rid of the CIA,
which he was.
I mean,
Kennedy was trying to pull us out of
Vietnam,
was trying to get rid of the CIA.
He was trying to get rid of the uh,
the um,
uh,
the,
the Federal Reserve here.
There was a lot of like super
controversial ideas that Kennedy was
trying to push forward and someone
killed him.
I always go to the simple thing,
which is why would Jack Ruby shoot him?
Right?
Yeah.
Cause a lot of people say,
oh,
he was just a patriot.
We've got mad and happened to be there.
But I,
which maybe makes perfect sense,
but if he was told to do it,
it's such a suicide end up in jail for
the rest of your life mission.
It doesn't matter to me.
It falls.
Things like that fall apart there.
That's what they do.
But it's also possible they told him,
listen,
just shoot him,
we'll get you off.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll find some sort of a way.
Like,
or they might've had something horrible
on him.
Jack Ruby was clearly embedded in the
mob.
The mob was angry at Kennedy because
they helped Kennedy when they helped him
win Illinois.
You know what I mean?
They helped him become the president and
there was absolute evidence that they
were mad at him once he became president
because then he started doing things
that were against their interest.
There was a lot of people pissed off at
Kennedy.
That's what's funny about the current
Russia scandal because it's a similar
thing where there's just so much going
on.
I keep saying that people,
you're not hearing this defense from all
the trump people.
Well,
we met with Peru eight times.
We met with English people like they are
just that having those meetings,
there's not all those connections with
any other country,
but Russia not only that,
this whole thing about Flynn and that
the,
the intelligence agencies were warning
that Flynn was compromised and that the,
he could be blackmailed by Russia.
Like they had things on him,
what they had on him,
we don't know,
but they're very convinced that there
was evidence against Flynn and that the
trump administration knew this and they
were still entertaining talks with them.
They're still bringing him on board.
And what's fascinating is this world of
international lobbyists,
like Paul Manafort,
what are they doing?
Did you,
did you see this a thing where Paul
manafort's kids,
someone hack their phones and they had
all these texts where they were talking
about how horrible their dad was.
Oh,
and how he's responsible for
people getting killed.
Oh No.
And they're seeing,
and who knows if any of that's true,
but there's a higher world of Americans
going overseas and being involved in
dirty politics and the work of,
uh,
governments like the Ukraine that we
don't have any clue about what that is.
Yeah.
It's on the last frontiers for really
diabolical shit.
You know,
like Russia is one of the last,
like what he had,
what he is,
what Putin stands for is,
uh,
like one of the last brutal military
dictators.
It's kind of in a costume.
Yes,
he's in a costume as the president of
Russia,
but we all know,
like,
he murders people that oppose him.
He murders journalists,
he murders political candidates that are
running against him.
I mean,
he's,
he's terrifying guy.
But what do you think it means that that
trump just love some just not good.
He just,
he did Myers.
I think he admires the take no shit guy.
Yeah,
I think he does and I think there's also
the possibility that he feels that what
Putin stands for is like he's a this
powerful superpower and it's better to
be friends with them than it is to be
enemies.
Let's just cozy up,
hey,
I wish I could do a lot of the shit you
do.
A lot of people talk shit about me on
twitter.
I wish I could have him killed.
I mean it's entirely possible that he
thinks along those lines because I think
it's probably from decades of trump
dealing with the mob in New York and
Atlantic city and he probably developed
a point of view about how you deal with
evil people.
Yeah.
And how you have to make deals and how
friends with them.
I think a lot of rich people think
everyone doesn't understand this is how
the world works.
This is how the sausage gets made and
that's why they do crazy stuff because
they just go,
everyone else is naive and just get me
in a room with and get me a back
channel.
We'll figure it out.
Like right.
The back channel with cushner,
it's like sitting down with a mob
figuring out your price for cement.
That's what he thinks the Putin back
channel is.
I believe we will figure it out.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll come up with,
and I think it seems like trump likes
the idea of that what you present is a
lie and what you do in private is
figuring out solutions and that that's
how the world works and that it's all
full of shit.
Yeah,
and that that is the way you get away
with everything.
That's how the world works.
That's a justification.
Hey,
it's how the world works,
which is so different than Bush who was
religious and had this thought,
we are going to go to other countries.
We're going to take down these leaders
and they are going to find freedom and
we're all going to change for the
positive when they don't have these
dictators.
Trump is an old school guy who's like,
you need the dictators to keep all these
assholes in line.
Yeah.
But meanwhile he's kind of right.
I mean,
look what happens when you take the
dictators out.
You create this power vacuum and the
places are way more chaotic.
Look at Libya,
right?
It's a failed state now.
He got rid of Qaddafi.
Everybody's happy.
Hillary Clinton was on TV.
They did an interview with her where
she's cheering.
She's like laughing at a week came,
we saw he died.
Ha Ha.
Do you see that?
Oh yes.
The air thing.
I think that's what makes the world so
impossible to manage right now.
Right.
Which is,
you know,
it's like,
we tried this,
this,
you know,
this approach of let's,
let's make these people a democracy,
but you can't force people to want a
democracy.
Also,
they're conditioned to being in a
dictatorship.
They've lived that way their whole life,
and there's all these other people.
When you get rid of Qaddafi,
it doesn't mean he's the only piece of
shit there.
There's a million other pieces of shit
that are wondering how they get to that
guy's position and he's keeping them
down and murdering people and trying to
keep keeping.
And so their entire life,
that's the paradigm they've operated
under.
They've watched this happen,
they've seen this one central brutal,
murderous figure control everyone else.
And when that's gone,
it's not all Kumbaya.
All the sudden it creates this power
vacuum and then everybody's clamoring to
see who takes that guy spot.
And now you have isis steps in and Libya
is just straight chaos.
And there's seems to be no solution to
almost no solution,
right?
Because there's a,
there's a massive religious tribal war
happening where if we,
if we didn't exist,
they were,
they would just be fighting each other.
Right?
And that's what happened.
That's what we were warned about with
Iraq.
Like people that didn't understand Iraq,
including Bush,
did not understand.
If you take Saddam Hussein out of the
picture,
who is kind of secular,
what you're left with is this Sunni Shia
up civil war.
And you're going to have this crazy
situation where there's two different
sects of Islam are going to kill each
other and no one saw that coming.
I mean,
well you know who did see that coming?
Janeane Garofalo she,
yeah,
cause I remember watching her on CNN and
there was a,
there was a massive protest against
going into Iraq before we went to war.
And she said,
this is what's going to happen if we go
there.
And she laid that out.
Well,
she's a Noam Chomsky Fan.
Yeah.
She said,
these people are going to attack each
other.
We're going to create a mess.
That is going to be,
we're gonna open a Pandora's box and
there are no weapons of mass destruction
and we should wait and we don't have
enough information.
And she really took a beating,
uh,
for being,
in strong opposition to invading Iraq.
And every single thing that you said
would happen in the next 10 years.
It happened.
And she wasn't the only person.
There were plenty of people.
I remember when nine 11 happened,
Norman mailer was on,
uh,
he was on Charlie rose like that week.
And he said,
this is exactly what's going to happen.
And he explained the wars that would
happen,
where they would happen.
He,
and then he,
and this is what's gonna happen
as a result of those wars and,
and laid out the mess that was created.
And he said,
you'll see,
we,
we do not have the strength to not take
these steps.
I should clarify.
I don't know if Janine's uh,
uh,
really,
Noam Chomsky Fan,
but I know chumps Chomsky was saying
that like,
he was pretty adamant about that.
Like very early on,
I just watched the Chomsky documentary
on Netflix.
It's an interesting guy.
Yeah.
And it was fascinating and it had one
simple idea,
which also I think a lot of people don't
realize,
uh,
which is just that our country,
how it's set up is,
is meant to protect people from the
people with money from the land owners.
As it was more back then.
And the basic theory is that
the people with the wealth and
corporations are not served by
democracy.
If democracy is functioning,
it is not in the favor of the wealthy or
corporate interests.
And so as a result,
they always have to be against democracy
because if they're,
if,
if Republicans don't have voter
suppression,
then everything is going to change in
favor of what the population wants to
do.
So that they'll always be incentives for
having less people vote and to,
to making democracy not function the way
that it should.
Cause clearly you could have voter motor
id where the,
when you get your driver's license,
you're registered for the whole country.
You could have everyone in the country
vote by mail,
you can have everyone vote by computer,
you can make it.
So we'd have 80,
90% of the people voting.
But that goes against corporate
interests.
And so they fight to say,
uh,
there's,
you know,
all these fake votes when there,
there isn't.
And so that protects corporate
interests.
And it's a,
it's a really interesting documentary
that just came up I guess in the last
year.
What's it called?
Um,
oh,
we're about to find out.
It's,
I see.
I liked it.
The computers to searching as we speak.
A lot of people that are resisting the
idea of people voting online.
But we bank online.
It's ridiculous.
Of course she'd be able to vote while we
certainly could get more people voting.
It's fascinating that there's other
countries like Russia trying to get into
that.
Oh,
requiem for the American dream.
Uh,
yeah.
It's,
it's worth it.
It's worth seeing.
I mean,
I,
I don't really,
you know,
some of these things I don't have the
strongest opinions on because it's
pretty,
it's very complicated and it's like you
said,
you just,
you never know what new,
messier creating.
I was talking to this actor,
right?
Um,
who does a lot of charity work around
the world,
very famous actor.
And he said,
you know,
I was working,
uh,
on this project to dig wells and a
community in Africa.
And then we dug the wells and his
incredible for this community and
then the neighboring community came and
murdered everybody for the wells.
He goes,
that's what it's like trying to save
people and to help people in the world.
There's always something that results
that you did not anticipate that makes
it even more complicated.
And I feel it's that way with most
issues that you think it's this,
but you've set off that and uh,
and it takes,
I would,
where I come down is you need an
incredibly intelligent person to be in
the middle of making these choices.
And just generally with trump,
I don't think he's that smart and I
think that he is very,
you know,
very self-involved,
narcissistic person and we can debate,
uh,
choices,
but it doesn't seem like the,
like the person who has the depth to
make these calls.
Well,
I don't think anybody really is
qualified to run 350 million people.
I just think it's a ridiculous
proposition,
but I think you're definitely right.
Also,
he,
he sets the tone for the mindset of the
country.
Yeah.
I mean it really is.
We have this Alpha male chimpanzee thing
going on where the one like robot Momma
love him or hate him,
was a very articulate,
really well spoken calm and measured
guy.
And I think that's very good for America
to have this guy who's smarter than
anybody you know,
and he's running the country like you
feel like,
okay,
well this guy is obviously,
look,
he,
he hardly ever stutters.
He knows what he's talking about.
And very moderate.
I mean,
when you get down to it,
what I find interesting is Obama was so
moderate after the banking issues,
he didn't go after the bankers.
He didn't send anyone to jail.
He propped up those businesses.
So the fact that the banks so want to
get rid of him,
it makes me go how much money is enough,
right?
This guy's still basically on your side.
Hillary's basically still on your side.
They were mad when their bonuses where
minimalized.
Yeah,
remember that.
Exactly.
I think that they got billions of
dollars in bail money and they still
wanted their bonuses.
I have a contract,
my contract says I got a bonus or just
thinking about their house and their
yacht and people got bonuses even though
the economy collapsed,
even though the economy class as a
direct result of the industry that they
were involved in and the businesses they
were running,
they still got bonuses.
It's really crazy and it was interesting
is that I guess most people,
they don't connect that and they're not
furious.
Like right now they're trying to get rid
of the compute,
the Consumer Protection Bureau that
keeps an eye on the bank.
So they're trying to Defang them.
And Pete,
you would think that people who want
their guns would also say,
but I would like consumer protection so
you don't screw me out of my credit
card.
Right.
But for some reason,
because it doesn't align it with their
team.
Exactly.
They don't care about the issues that
are,
that would protect them.
Isn't that super dangerous to have a
right and a left I,
it's just
cause you always do,
you go for independent candidates a lot.
Right.
You're looking for a third party and
what prevents there from being a logical
third party?
Well,
I think we had it with Ross Perot,
right?
I think Ross Perot was a logical third
party and it became very dangerous for
people.
And that's one of the reasons why the
commission for presidential debates
changed the threshold.
Like you back then,
you needed 5% in the primary in order to
be included in the debates.
You put Ross Perot and the debate is an,
uh,
an independent [inaudible] extremely
wealthy man who understands a lot about
tax codes,
understands a lot about foreign
relations,
and he became like a huge problem and
most likely cost.
Uh,
Herbert Walker Bush his second term,
right?
Yes.
And then that's why Clinton became
president in the first place.
And the threshold is what now to get
into those debates,
Bernie Sanders is kind of an
independent,
right?
I mean,
he's obviously that his parties not on
his side,
and we proved that with the DNC leaks
that they're,
they're conspiring against him.
This is his actual own party,
which is the same as changing the
thresholds of the third party candidate.
Can't be in the debates.
Right,
right.
It's just another version of that.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's another version of that.
Well then you find out the condition for
presidential debates is I,
it's,
it's not even a national thing.
It's like a privately funded thing.
It's a,
it's a private company.
Like they can choose like how they like
what like,
oh,
let's make it 15%.
You have to get 15% and then they could
just change it.
Like that guy was a problem.
That guy was a pain in the ass.
Let's change the threshold.
Yeah.
What could go wrong?
Are you,
I mean there are people who feel like
left and right are the same thing when
you really get down to it or they're
protecting the same interests in some
way.
Are you a believer in that or not?
I think that the,
most of the people that are on the left
and most of the people on the right
aren't even really thinking about
whatever their party stands for.
They are just like they said,
they are sticking with the team,
whether it's the left team,
have the right team.
I think,
um,
I think radical ideologies,
whether it's on the left or the right,
will they share a lot of common traits.
And one of the things that they share is
the,
this complete lack of objectivity,
lack of objectivity and lack of
introspective thought in terms of like
what their party is actually doing and
what it means to be a liberal,
what it means to be progressive,
what it means to be Republican,
what it means to be conservative.
You just get into this groove like this
is what we do,
fuck global warming.
It's not real.
You know,
and then fuck this and you can't be
racist against a white person.
Like you.
People have these ridiculous ideas on
the left and on the right.
They just dig their heels in the sand.
They didn't even think about and they
just go with it because that's what the
party says.
And it's just the game because they have
kind of election night,
I called a lot of politicians and a
bunch of journalists was just trying to
get a sense of what's going on.
How could I get involved with was there
to do.
And it was really dispiriting.
It was all reactive.
Everyone was like,
well,
we have to see what they do to decide
how to react.
And I
was like,
so you were just super upset that trump
won?
Yeah,
I could see what was about to happen.
And everything I was concerned about did
happen.
But they basically all said,
well,
you have to let him do his thing to then
react and then have the population react
to what he did.
And did you have any concerns at all
about hillary?
Well,
I,
I think,
uh,
it reminded me a little bit of a,
I mean,
I'm aware of what those issues are,
but I do think,
you know,
there are large choices that just affect
millions and hundreds of millions of
people.
Like for instance,
when a guy like Donald Trump says,
we're not going to give money to any aid
service around the world that says
anything about abortion,
forget giving out abortions.
If they hand out a pamphlet and it says
that's an option,
they don't get money.
So if you're a country in Africa and
there's only one aids aid service,
I like feeds starving people.
But you also hand out a pamphlet on
abortion.
You don't get any of the money anymore.
I agree.
That was fucked up and a lot of the
things he does are fucked up.
But did you have any problems at all
with Hillary?
Like did you know I had a big issue that
she does not seem to understand a
certain issues like the speech getting
paid for the speeches that,
that her blind spot and she has revealed
to still have it after the election that
like,
uh,
why did I go there?
Cause I got paid,
uh,
you know,
I guess they've made,
over a hundred million dollars giving
speeches bill and Hillary Clinton,
which on one level you go,
yeah,
you know,
people don't understand.
I'm going to go do a,
a standard corporate gig and it's crazy
money.
There's a crazy corporate speech money
floating up.
Yeah,
but wait a minute.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not defending it yet.
I'm just saying she has a blind spot to
what?
To the potential for corruption that
people see in that and that she,
when you're,
when you're getting,
I mean,
well one article said it was like $150
billion between the two of them over
like 10 years or so.
The fact that she doesn't even have a
good game to,
to defend it,
that you can't go up against trump and
say he's corrupt while you're getting
that much money from corporate
interests.
Like she never even saw how offensive it
was.
That kind of thing that Bernie Sanders
doesn't do.
So people go,
well,
at least he's not lining his pockets
with that money.
Hillary is basically saying,
I,
I lined my pockets with that money,
but I still have my own opinions and the
blind spot at least to the outrage of it
is something that I,
I had threw me.
But ultimately the main choices that she
wanted to make on a lot of issues are so
much more in line with what I believe
than trump.
That,
although not a perfect candidate,
you know,
trump is doing,
he's,
he's trying to get this healthcare thing
through and doesn't seem
that concerned about the amount of
people are you get kicked off.
So I,
I guess there are certain things I
sucked up about it.
I didn't have a core thing that she's
like a terrible person,
but I think it,
it's,
it's pretty hard to get me to that place
with people.
I always need a little bit more proof of
that.
But certainly she represents someone who
is dishonest though.
And that's a real problem when you don't
have a leader of this incredible country
and someone who's clearly dishonest and
it's been dishonest for a long time.
Like when they talk to her about the
emails,
every interview she gave about it,
she would give varying responses.
A lot of them were dishonest.
A lot of it was not based on facts when
she compared what she said Komi said to
her during the investigation versus what
Comi was saying publicly,
they were totally different things.
Oh,
I,
I totally understand it.
I think that there's a lot of politics
that's really bad and really dirty and I
don't know enough on each specific thing
that have a,
you know,
a position on each thing that she said.
But I do feel like there are people who
are playing the game with service in
mind and maybe they're getting dirty or
making mistakes with service in mind.
And then there are people like trump
that I really don't understand why he's
there.
And His general philosophy is let the
smart rich people get richer and
something nice might happen for you that
he's so dishonest on a level that you
can't compare it to.
It's just so,
I mean he admits that he's a liar.
Uh,
no,
I'm fully with you on this.
But whenever people criticize trump or
whenever the people talk about Hillary
rather the f one of the first things
they do is say trump is worse.
They,
instead of like talking about how weird
like,
oh,
she's such an non ideal candidate.
Like she was such a terrible candidate.
She didn't believe in gay marriage until
2013 you mean 2013 she was publicly
stating that gay marriage should be,
it should not be legal,
that a marriage,
a legal marriage should be between a man
and a woman.
And clearly for only political reasons,
like she obviously had exact issue with
it at all.
And I agree with you,
I feel like there is a part of politics
where people,
you know,
like say my position was evolving on
that one.
No,
your position wasn't evolving.
You just weren't fighting for what you
actually believe.
Obama took a while to make big moves on
that.
But I still think at core people like
that are trying to figure out the system
to help people.
And I can't say I understand what trump
has in this for other than to be
considered the greatest winner of all
time.
Yeah,
I think that's probably exactly it.
I don't think he really wanted to be
president.
I think he was doing it sort of boost
his brand and along the way he lost the
television show right when he's doing
all that,
build that wall shit.
And,
but running the wall just got 10 feet
higher and NBC was like,
Fuck you man,
we're canceling your show.
And when they did that,
I think he was like,
Oh yeah,
well I'm really going to be fucking
president.
And he kept going
and going and going and then he won.
I mean it seems to me like the whole
thing was started almost as a publicity
campaign,
like a fun thing.
What if his people said that there was a
woman in publicity for him who left?
She's the only person I knew who left
the campaign for this reason,
I forgot her name,
but it was very public.
This wasn't a it.
She said it publicly that when it
started,
the plan was to come in second to help
the brand,
to get some fame,
to make some statements about what he
believes with no belief that it was
possible that he would do better than
second in the Republican primaries.
And then the woman said as it became
clear that they had a really good shot
of winning.
She said,
oh,
I wasn't in it for this.
And what I find fascinating to watch is
trump's slowly getting comfortable with
power as as he thinks he's figuring it
out is interesting.
Like,
uh,
I mean even the Jerrod cushner thing is
kind of hilarious.
You have this son in law,
so now you have a blind spot that anyone
in the world thinks it's weird that you
give your son in law are real estate
developers so much power and he doesn't
care at all because he doesn't trust
anybody except like four people.
So he's got to give them all the power,
but he puts them in charge of fixing
everything wrong with the infrastructure
of governments and the Middle East and
two or three other things.
And trump doesn't understand how insane
that appears.
And also how each task is impossible.
Like this is my son when he's going to
fix government and the Middle East,
the type of guy that doesn't realize,
well maybe there's one person for each
of those jobs is,
that's where I just go,
oh,
he's full out crazy.
Because who would even do that to their
son in law?
Maybe his son in law is a pain in the
ass.
He's like,
this fucking kid thinks he could do
things.
All right,
I'll give you the worst job ever.
Go fix government.
Go fix the Middle East.
I got it.
I'm going to prove my worth to you sir.
And Ray Ban Sunglasses and his preppy
outfit.
I mean it,
it's become so comical.
You know,
it's a fascinating thing because it's
both terrifying and comical.
Like if this was a movie,
it's too broad and you wouldn't believe
it.
You would just go to much.
It's happening in every scene.
Too many crazy thoughts and what I
guess,
I guess what I wonder,
I mean maybe you have an opinion about
this.
There are people who say,
you know,
it is the destruction of truth when you
just make these lies up all day long,
that you changed the definition of truth
or even people's ability to decide what
they think is the truth.
Is that a philosophy that someone like
bannon is executing in the White House
or something that happens randomly and,
and,
and is organic out of them?
That's a real good question.
I mean,
there's always the concept.
Absolute power corrupts absolutely.
And knowing that you're in some sort of
a competition,
knowing that you are,
uh,
there's people trying to knock you down
and you're in this position of power and
you're shoring up your defenses.
And I think there's a lot of weird stuff
that goes on whenever you're the winning
team and you realize you're being
attacked at all angles by this other
team.
And then you've got this guy who's the
head guys,
a fucking maniac.
He's got fake hair.
He puts a spray Tan on every day.
He's out there as his eyes are white.
No one tells him his face,
his orange.
He's saying insane shit.
He contradicts himself all the time.
He lies all the time about numbers.
He's always bragging about how well his
ratings are and how shows do really well
because everybody knows he watches the
show.
It's crazy stuff that you just don't
expect from someone who's in the
position of president of the United
States.
I think almost all bets are off at this
point.
That's the one thing that I find
promising about this,
that people are so upset by how fucked
up this it is.
This is that they're going to get
politically active and that they're
going to realize like there's some real
holes in the system,
like the FBI,
like the president shouldn't just be
able to fire the head of the FBI because
you don't like the investigation like of
yourself sane and,
and,
and sessions recused himself,
but he can fire the guy investigating
himself.
Insane.
It's all insane.
But I,
I guess what my fear would be is that
when it just swings back the other way,
like you could just swing left,
right,
right.
But are any institutional protections
that were put in place because it just
swings back up.
But like for instance say like we don't,
you know,
I'm not an expert in healthcare,
but let's assume it's just a shit storm.
Right?
And in,
in a year or two,
whatever millions of people are losing
the healthcare and everyday you're just
hanging about hundreds of people who
have cancer who can't pay for their
medicine.
What happens in this country?
Do People get mad at the Republicans?
Did they vote them out or to somehow not
enough sick people?
There's not enough sick people to make
the change.
I think there's so many issues.
There's so many issues that like where
do you draw the line?
Do you draw the line at them?
Taking the teeth out of the EPA,
which is what they're done.
Environmental Protection Agency is
fucked now.
I mean they were moving the satellites
that track global warming,
they're,
they're stopping funding for all these
different initiatives and all these
different programs and all these
different studies.
They're trying to figure out what the
fuck is going on at the plant.
They were like that,
that the stop all that.
What we really need is Enron and Exxon,
all these different companies,
big conglomerates,
big corporations.
We need to drill,
we need to drill,
we need to frack,
we need to go over where,
you know,
Alaska and we're in the Antarctic.
We get in that ground,
pull that oil out and,
and it's,
it's,
that's,
that's scary.
And then you hear the healthcare shit.
Well,
well that's scary too.
And then you hear the Russian shit.
Well that's scary.
North Korea.
Oh,
that's scary.
There's so many different things to be
scared about.
I don't think the people who don't have
cancer don't have diseases are really
considering all this healthcare stuff.
I think it's one of those things that
happens.
Once you have a health issue,
then you realize how fuck the system is
and especially if you don't have the
money to take care of it,
you're like,
wow,
like our medical system in this country
is not,
it's not the best.
We have the best doctors.
We certainly have the best surgeons and
we have some pretty amazing innovative
medicine.
But when it comes to like the,
the system itself for like when you find
out how much people have to pay when
they go to the doctor and how about you
eve,
you have insurance but the insurance
only covers so much.
You still have to pay more.
Sure.
By,
by my mom died of ovarian cancer.
And I just remember going through those
bills and there was a lot of
experimental medicine that potentially
could save her.
And you didn't know if insurance would
say this is the type of approach that
they are willing to pay for.
Right.
And anything you needed to do,
you'd have to prove you needed it.
Someone says you needed a new cat scan
and you've had to that ear,
you might have to go to a war to say why
you need it now.
Right.
And uh,
I remember crunchers,
I'm just always fascinated that it
doesn't line up for people.
Like you say you love the outdoors and
you love hunting.
Well don't you love the environment,
right?
And so why are you not really pissed or
trumps going to build a wall and he's
going to take a lot of people's land
away to build the wall?
Well,
I thought that was the big issue for all
of these militia groups don't mess with
our land.
Yeah.
And so there's always going to do is
going to take land away to build the
wall.
The only way to build the wall in a lot
of those plots of land,
a lot of private lands.
I mean it's a,
it's a,
that's a jagged path when you're
building that wall and you have to,
you know,
you have to take away a lot of people's
lands to pull that off.
Uh,
so that's what scares me the most about
America's.
There's an ilogic to people's opinions.
I think there's too many variables.
I think there's too many things to,
for people to consider.
And I think people work all day and then
they have hobbies and families and
things they enjoy doing and they don't
have the time to really sit.
I mean each one of those issues would
require a full time job all day long
investigating,
exacerbating it,
discussing it,
whether it's Flynn's ties to Russia or
what session knows and how many times
did he speak to the Russians or what
did,
what did jared cushner actually do in
the Middle East?
Like what is he doing in the overlap?
Cause each one of those is a full time
job.
What does he sing to Netanyahu alone in
the room.
How do they let him do that?
He looks like such a Dork.
Did you see the pictures of him with a
bulletproof vest on overseas?
And he's hanging around with the actual
soldiers and he's sitting there with his
ray bans on masking tape with his name
magic markered on it.
And it's,
it's a comedy.
And I have to say as a creative person
who's going to be at the Wilbur Oh,
uh,
when,
when he to go,
what am I get the Wilbur,
this is called the mid show.
A plug.
Everybody,
uh,
the Wilburn Boston,
just added a late show for charity for
the afterschool programs for Boston
Arts,
July 24th,
the wilbur.com.
One of my favorite theaters in the
warpath and the best crowds.
Amazing.
It's incredible.
And it feels like you're in a club.
There's a thousand people in there,
but they're all in three tiers.
Yeah.
And so it's very short.
It's like three,
300 seat comedy clubs jammed in there
together.
It's the perfect layout for common.
It really is.
And then I'll be in a providence,
Rhode Island at the Columbus Theater.
Uh,
July 25th and at the Richfield playhouse
in Ridgefield,
Connecticut.
July 23rd and I'm taping my special Ed
Montreal,
the just for laughs festival because
they seem to be amused by me then.
Oh,
that's an amazing place to do it at the
festival and the festival.
Yeah.
How many shows are you going to do?
I'm doing five shows.
I'm taping four of them.
Oh,
that's a good move.
I like that.
I like when I hear that.
I hate when I hear someone taping one
show.
No,
no.
I,
I could panic and ruin one show.
I can,
I can actually,
if I did only two shifts,
I can panic the first show and then go,
okay,
now I only have one show to get it and
panic again.
Who are you doing your special for?
Uh,
for Netflix.
Oh yeah.
That's the way to go.
It was my turn.
Nice.
And so
I haven't done something like that
since.
Basically the HBO Young Comedian Special
in 1992 with the Ray Romano,
the guy who got fired.
So you could have your career.
No,
I didn't.
He got fired.
So somebody else could take it.
And then that guy fired and I got two
kids.
I don't know who is the in between.
Guy was on the pilot,
there was a guy on the pilot that was
not ray ray got fired and another guy
took his spot and then that guy fired
and I took that guy spot.
I'll Paul Simms is vicious.
Vicious.
He was going to get it done right around
a little bit of in the news radio days
just as a friend of Paul's and Andy
Dicks.
And that show is a show that holds up
and is really funny.
Well I was just happy that there was a
buffer between me and rang cause I love
Ray.
I would not have wanted to be the guy
that takes Ray's job.
I think ray is one of the first people
to tell you he probably was not prepared
as an actor at that exact moment.
What was the wrong gig forum?
Everybody loves Raymond was the perfect
gay.
Yes.
Let him write for himself and let him
figure it all out and become obsessed
with it.
He's such a good guy.
Oh,
he's the best.
Ray Romano was like one of the nicest
people I've ever met.
And so good in our movie.
The big sick.
Honestly,
the dream part.
So funny.
So real,
very,
I mean it's the culmination of
everything he's learned as an actor and
a,
and a and a person.
Uh,
so I'm very excited about that.
Just doing that tbs things doing like a
drama for awhile yet men of a certain
age depress dudes.
That's what I called it,
a bunch of depressed dudes.
I called it the Judd apatow story
and yeah,
he's,
he's so,
he's so good.
He was on parenthood for awhile.
Um,
and I've gotten to spend a little time
with him because of this movie,
but it is funny that we were on the
young comedian special in 1992.
That is amazing.
And now you're back at it and now and
now I'm back doing it again.
You've done stand up now for three years
since yeah.
Since uh,
2000 for three years straight.
Yeah.
And then like what,
like how many years in where you like,
I think I've got a special here.
They asked me to do it a year ago and I
said,
okay,
give me one more year.
So that's very honest of you.
Well,
you know,
everybody's so good.
I mean,
I was performing the other night and the
original room and you were in the main
room and I could hear the place rocking
from the stage of the original room.
Maybe bike ride was too quiet that I
could hear you.
I could hear your last and you just,
you know,
talking loud and I,
and so I always think,
wow,
people are so good right now.
People,
people are masters at this and I can't
be mediocre at it.
I mean,
I'm in the same business as you and
Maria Bamford and Louis Ck and Hannibal
and I have to be able to be proud of
what I'm doing.
So Joey Diaz and bill bird,
this is a different time or so many
murderers out there right now.
Yeah,
I mean I was watching Burr,
I did a largo show that he was on and I
was just watching him from the side of
the stage and just his level of
intensity is so,
you know,
in a weird way it's so professional and
I notice it with you the other night too
that you could get yourself in that
state where you care so much and you're
so passionate and it requires so much
energy and focus to get to that place,
to perform with that passion.
It's just really impressive cause like
for me I can just get tired and starts
tearing a night.
How did it get tired?
Halfway through like,
oh like it's just felt a wave of like,
like after you eat a big meal and you
just get tired,
like it just hit you eight minutes.
What I'm always trying to accomplish is
trying to get out whatever I'm trying to
talk about with the most power that I
can like the most.
Like what's the best way to do it is the
best way to do it.
Slow and calm and let people soak in the
idea or is the best way to do it to be
intense and like what is like the most
entertaining way that I would be
engaging this material,
figure whatever that is and and fuck
with it and moving around and bring it
up and bring it down.
And that's one of the things where the
store is such a great place to focus on
that kind of stuff because there's so
many killers because of the standards
are so high that you have to really,
you really have to be on point and it's
packed every night you go to the comedy.
So the main room would use it as be
desolate like four years ago.
It's sold out like it's vegas every
night.
Every night I walk in there like I got
some new jokes.
I'm like,
can I do,
how many new jokes can I do when this is
a big sold out excited crowd,
which changed the face of comedy in La.
Now,
I mean comedy in La is a different thing
now.
The last few years.
It's also funny how a place like the
comedy store,
you know our friend Adam,
uh,
he got
who who books it.
Just one guy with good tastes booking
the club well and suddenly everyone in
town wants to run to that club.
Again,
both comedians and the audience because
Adam does such a good job looking at
opening up that back bar where you gave
us a place where the public can't go on
a comics can go and hang out.
That was giant where there was a place
to chill and hang out.
People with like you'd be sitting there
with Ron Wyden,
allow,
I'm on in five c your boys and he'd go
out there and do a set.
Then Diaz would come back and all these
different people are hanging out there.
You're like,
wow,
like this place is like something
special.
Like they,
they made changes,
they figured things out,
they did things differently.
Yeah.
I missed just hanging out with comics
when I wasn't doing stand up.
I was like,
I don't know anybody anymore.
Like,
I literally don't know anybody that just
the idea of being a part of that
community and it is a community of
people that are really smart,
you know,
really,
really funny.
And I think generally incredibly
supportive community to each other.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well I think especially now there's so
many opportunities I don't think people
feel like is starved.
I think there was a famine mentality
that was going on way back in the day
when it was everybody competing for
tonight show spots and then every now
and then someone got an hbo special and
it was Holy Shit there was not that many
hbo specials.
But other than that you had to do talk
shows and you had to do like a few
minutes on a talk show or you know,
maybe you were like a Richard Jenny who
thrived in that format and you could do
30 tonight show things and then fill up
arenas because of that.
But for most people it was a scratch and
claw environment and people were
fighting to try to get a sitcom and
fighting to try to get movie roles and
all these,
there was not a lot.
But now because of the Internet,
because of Youtube,
because of social media and then a
Netflix,
which was giant,
there's so much opportunity like,
and the comedians have also found way
more of an audience.
There's way more audience out there
because people realize like,
Oh look,
Sarah Silverman has a new netflix
special.
Oh look,
Jim Jefferies has a new netflix special.
I'll look bill burroughs and who?
Netflix special.
And just keeps going and going and going
and going and going.
It's like,
it's almost unstoppable.
And I remember when I was a kid,
there was nothing.
It was just like Robert Klein would have
a special every couple of years now.
And then George Carlin every couple of
years,
they didn't give the hours too many
people.
And there were so many people that
probably could have done a netflix
special back then.
Sure.
And they didn't have the audience.
They never got the shot.
And,
you know,
they just sort of stayed at a certain
state in their career forever.
Yeah.
You know,
it's just,
this is an amazing,
amazing time for it.
Yeah.
And it's good.
I mean,
I watch people,
I'm like,
God damn,
that's,
people are fucking great.
I mean,
I'd really like watch people.
I was watching Ray Romano the other
night,
his act was just monstrous.
Yeah.
He was so strong.
Have you seen the Andrew Santina at the
store?
Oh yeah.
Fine.
Let's go.
I'm going to end up here.
I mean,
it's so good.
I,
it's uh,
it's exciting.
I can't think about it too much because
sometimes I think there's so many people
why do it?
But I'm trying to
make it very much about the audience and
me and that,
you know,
because I make movies and do tv that my
standup career really is just about
getting to hang out with everybody and
my relationship with that particular
crowd that night.
Like I don't need it to pay the rent,
so I could do it from a very pure place
cause it's just about these
interactions.
That's great.
You know?
And so,
and it frees me up to not be nervous and
then I can be a little more daring
because it's not going to going to sink
me if anything goes wrong.
Do you think that it enhances your
ability to make movies?
Does it enhance your perspective?
Oh yeah.
It's a funny,
I think that when you don't talk
directly to the crowd,
you get stale as to what people are
thinking about.
You know,
I can tell,
I don't know,
just when I bring up certain topics,
just what people's concerns are and it
happens unconsciously.
Oh,
this is what people find funny these
days.
This is what people are freaking out
about.
This is what people are happy about.
And when you don't do it,
you're just alone in a room with your
editor.
You're just sitting in it with you
sitting with one dude for two years.
And I think,
uh,
I also think you're connecting to some,
you know,
whatever,
your,
the creativity of the universe because
you're in spaces with a lot of people,
with a lot of other creative people and
you're hooking into creativity on some
level.
I've always wondered how comedy writers
who don't do standup can do it.
I've always wondered like,
how do they know?
It's funny like how do they know what's
what they're guessing?
Well,
it's weird to write jokes,
make a movie,
and then two years later find out if
they're funny.
That's our,
that's why people say,
Oh,
why do you have so much improv?
Because I don't want to be in an editing
room.
Put in the joke.
I wrote realize it sucks and then go,
do we have any other jokes?
And the editor Says No.
Ooh.
So I always want like I it with any
scene,
I always go,
well that's where the joke supposed to
be.
Here's my favorite,
let's get eight more and low and then
we'll move on.
I never think like when there's people
like the Coen brothers and it's
verbatim,
you can't change a comma when they shoot
it.
Is that what is good?
What is with them?
It's like a play and I respect it,
but I do not have the courage to assume
when I hit editing that I am such a
genius that I will not have fucked up
any of this in the writing.
They have a weird kind of comedy though.
They're comedy is so quirky and
fascinating,
like,
and I guess maybe it's just that,
that purity of vision that they have.
Sure.
And sticking to that script.
And a lot of people do that.
I mean,
uh,
no,
a bomb back does that and you know,
you can't change any of it.
But I always think,
I don't know if,
uh,
if an actor's a said Ray Romano was on
the set of the big sick and he's talking
about his feelings and he has the scene,
if I go,
uh,
you know,
Michael Showalter,
director of that movie,
Hey,
let,
let them do another one.
Let's just let him change it this,
but tell him to hit the same idea.
Right.
Half the time he beats the joke at the
time.
Yeah.
If you have the right cast,
well
that was what sims did on Newsradio.
He led everybody just come up with
better lines.
It was a big part of why the show works
so well.
It's like we all felt really invested in
the creative process and that's so rare
and that's,
I remember it was shandling would do
that on a [inaudible] should.
They would rehearse for several days and
in that rehearsal people were allowed to
screw around and if something good came
up,
Gary would would write it down.
And Hartman was the funniest.
Phil Hartman really was,
you know,
when you really make the list of the
funniest people of all time,
he's just so high up on that list.
It was a remarkable thing.
I would go to tapings of that show and
SNL tapings and at one point I was
talking about writing an Hbo special
with him and I don't know if there's
ever been anyone more challenge in more
ways than him now.
He was brilliant.
He did.
He really was incredibly disciplined to
why when I was on the set with them,
he was becoming a pilot and so he was a,
in the middle of scenes he would be
reading flight books and reading books
on aviation and,
and writing notes and taking notes.
His,
he was so organized like his scripts,
he would put them all in a binder,
he would take the script immediately.
You put three punch,
put it in a binder and he would have
tabs for each of his scenes and each tab
had a different color.
This is scene one,
scene two.
And he would have everything set up like
that and have this line's highlighted
and he would practice them and have them
down to like a razor sharp.
Yeah,
it was amazing.
He was a really,
really,
really interesting guy.
A very unique,
I don't think I've ever met anybody like
him because he also came out of,
uh,
he was a designer and scientist.
Yeah.
Did album covers and stuff.
And,
and he said that he got Saturday night
live because he went in for the audition
and he was retiring because his career
hadn't worked out the way he wanted it
to.
And then someone said,
do you want to go in for snl?
And he was so ready to be done that he
had an amazing audition cause he assumed
he wouldn't get it.
And basically it was like,
fuck this business.
And then that's the moment when he was
in his purest funny itself and just got
it.
Oh,
interesting guy,
man.
He was blackmailed while we were on the
show.
And a while we're on the show,
he and his wife actually had went to a
strip club and this was like 1997,
97,
98,
somewhere around there.
So,
uh,
this some asshole at a strip club,
got a video camera,
brought in a video camera and filmed
like a fucking video camera back then.
And he filmed phil and his wife at a
strip club laughing,
just having a couple of drinks.
And I think phil got a lap dance and his
wife got a lap dance and then they laugh
and he this guy,
um,
put a copy of this video tape in an
envelope and nailed it to Phil's garage
door.
Oh fuck.
With a note saying,
cause I had Herman's thing.
It was scary shit.
Yeah,
but it was different because Letterman,
his thing was someone he knew.
And this was not a guy I knew and this
is the guy who found out where Phil
lived and said,
I'm going to get this to uh,
all of the advertisers that you know,
you do commercials with and all the
people that you do films with and I'm
going to ruin your career unless you
give me money.
Call me at this number that I left his
fucking number.
So Phil calls the Guy Records the thing
and we did it in the room with me and he
goes,
I'm going to call the guy now.
I'm gonna call the guy now we shut.
And he goes,
hey buddy,
what's going on?
Listen,
I understand what you're saying,
but you got to realize like,
I don't have as much money as you think
I do.
And I mean this is coming.
I don't want the tape getting out.
But I mean you're making it out like
it's a bigger deal than it is.
And the guy was like,
look,
I'm,
I'm telling you and this that,
and the guy was like,
look,
I'm willing to work with you.
Let's just come to a reasonable
reasonable number.
So they come to this reasonable number
in this whole time where he's doing
this,
he's recording this and he gets it to
this private investigator guy and then
this asshole meets the private
investigator thinking he's going to meet
Phil and get paid.
And this private investigator guy scares
that fucking shit out of him and
threatens his life and you know,
takes his wallet from him,
takes photos of his,
you know,
his address and you know,
basically says,
don't ever contact him again or your
life will radically change in a horrible
way.
And the guy disappeared.
But it was weird to be in the room with
them and feels like close to dark too.
I'm going to call him.
I was like wiping his hands.
Sounds like an Anthony Pelicano special.
Uh,
exactly what we're talking about.
Yeah,
that's exactly what we're talking about.
That's a,
that's a ray Donovan Shit.
Yeah,
it's Ray Donovan Shit.
It was weird.
It was weird to be there for that to see
like it is also to see like that someone
would like try to weasel in on them.
Phil was just such a nice guy.
Just he knew this dude that was like a
carpenter.
The guy did some work with them.
The guy called him out of this halt,
call them horrible sob story.
You know,
we're going to lose our house and this
and that and I just,
you know,
just give me a little bit of a loan.
Okay.
So Phil gives them like $25,000 just
gives this guy and then the guy calls
him three months later and he asked for
another 30 and that feels like,
what the fuck man,
you know,
like he was just almost too nice.
That's about how it usually goes with
that.
It is,
yeah.
You never lend someone money and then
they go,
you know what?
You solved all my problems and now I'm
fine and here's the money back.
It just anybody money.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Did anybody ever pay you back?
Yes.
I always to tell this story just because
it's funny.
My friend Dave Raff who manages Pete
Holmes at some point was like
transitioning and starting his own
management company and asked me for some
money.
Not much,
but the only guy who ever paid me back
and quickly.
Yeah,
and that makes sense.
And it is a great man and is producing
my netflix special.
Ah,
well that works.
But the only guy to ever do what he said
he was going to do.
Yeah.
It's always these people that,
dude,
once this happens and this is going to
happen and I'm going to be making this
amount of money and don't worry about
it,
it's all going to come,
but just need a little right now.
It never happened.
Someone said the second people ask for
money,
they resent you.
And so even if you give people money,
they're mad that they had to ask and
they kind of hate you because you had to
ask you,
Ooh,
that's interesting.
Which,
which I,
which is certainly what you feel.
Well,
there's also the people that think that
the way to make it is to get somebody
else to get you through.
Like you gotta you gotta call on favors,
you gotta,
you gotta have connections.
You've got to get your way through that
way that that's the way to do it.
Somebody gave you a break,
man.
He didn't give me a break.
Somebody gave you a break.
It's like,
it's just,
that mentality is so wrong.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
one thing I'm proud of in my career is
they really was.
I had no ins at all.
You know,
I just,
you know,
my parents got divorced.
They were both bankrupt.
I started interviewing comedians from my
high school radio station at some point
I got Jamie Masada from the laugh
factory,
the who owns the laugh factory.
He had a magazine in the 80s and he
printed an interview I did with David
Brenner.
And I think I did another one with Henny
youngman.
Then when I moved here in [inaudible]
85,
uh,
I tried to get spots of this laugh
factory and it was still hard to get up
there,
but I didn't know anybody.
And the person who really hooked me up
with Sammy shore,
wow.
Same Insurance,
started the comedy store it,
then he got divorced and Mitzi took it
over and made it the great place it is.
But he started a comedy room in Marina
del Ray called Sammie's by the shore in
the back of a fish restaurant.
And he let me book it.
And in return I was allowed to go on and
maybe I got 40 bucks a week.
And that's how I got stage time for the
first year when I didn't know what I was
doing.
I would book that club,
which also gave me an excuse to call all
the comics who I admired.
And,
and it's funny,
like there's those people at a key
moment opened the door for you,
but it's not because you knew them,
it's just because you're willing to put
it all the work somehow.
Right,
right.
That's interesting,
man.
Sammie's by the shore.
I never heard about that one.
Do you remember the Valley Improv?
They had one in the Hilton in Sherman
Oaks.
No,
I wasn't around for that.
And the year was that,
it was like late eighties I wasn't here
until 94 oh yeah,
the late eighties and this guy,
Joe drew,
just the manager.
Great Young Guy.
I don't know where he is.
He used to say to me,
Judd,
come in,
wait around.
If somebody doesn't show up,
I'll put you up.
And I was like 19 years old and I would
wait there all night,
every night.
Thrilled to talk to everyone because
that's what right when Sandler moved to
town and David spade and,
and Schneider.
And that's when I first met everybody
and that guy would put me on.
And you know,
that's the funny thing about a career.
It's two or three who,
who change everything for you.
This is woman Mary parents who was one
of the heads of universal and I was,
I sold her the 40 old virgin and she
said,
Judd,
the second you hand in the script,
I'm going to green light it.
I so believe in this idea and you and
Steve.
And I literally faxed her like page 90
to 108 and then she called and said,
okay,
start prepping facts.
Yeah,
faxed it.
I'm that crazy.
Joe,
here's my question for you.
Okay,
let's,
let's talk my workout for a second.
Let's Talk My,
uh,
Omega Brain,
Alphabet Alpha right
now,
Pete Holmes turned me onto the Alpha
brain and oddly,
it completely works 100% and I'm,
it's all based on science.
I mean,
we have double blind placebo controlled
studies.
It's not something we invented in terms
of like the,
the actual nutrients and their response
to human neurotransmitter's.
It's all been documented.
People have known about nutrition
[inaudible] for a long time now.
And I always feel like I'm the perfect
test case for a product like that
because most days I go in a room with 11
writers in the morning.
I'm as tired and it is foggy as you can
be.
I do not drink coffee,
so I don't,
you don't drink coffee at all?
I just don't like it.
So I just,
the only coffee I like his ice blended
Mocha is,
which is all sugar.
Right.
So I avoided,
uh,
and when I uh,
started taking that I would completely
wake up and be sharp without like some
weird caffeine was or sick from it or
whatever.
And I would see it every day.
Like wow,
I was funny as hell for the last two and
a half hours and I did not start in that
place.
So I'm fascinated by your general
program,
like what you're doing all day with all
this stuff.
Like what's,
what's the current Joe Program?
Well,
um,
always doing something,
you know.
And in terms of like diet you mean or in
terms of like
the workout with the Diet,
what's the meditation?
What's the main tenants of your day?
Well,
my workout,
I schedule every Sunday.
I schedule everything that I'm going to
do during the week.
I say I have to do yoga two times this
week.
I have to lift weights three times this
I have to run twice this week.
And however I fit that in,
I fit that in.
But I owe those things.
Okay.
So I have to get those things in.
The only exceptions are injuries and
sickness.
So those,
that,
that's the,
the,
the schedule.
And then on top of that,
uh,
there's other things that I enjoyed
doing.
Kickboxing,
Jujitsu,
work those in when I can.
Then,
um,
diet.
The Diet is pretty strict in terms of
like no bread,
very few carbs,
no sugar,
no bullshit,
like healthy food,
a lot of vegetables,
a lot of meat,
game meat,
mostly wild game.
And I take vitamin supplements every
day.
I take multivitamins,
I take probiotics,
I take a vitamin B,
12 and D and a lot of different things.
I just,
um,
I do everything that I can to put my
body and my brain in a good place so
that I'm keeping my engine smooth.
I'm changing my oil,
I'm changing my spark plugs.
I'm making sure that it's operating.
I mean it's not going to be perfect,
but yeah,
I know that I've done my best to keep it
working the best that it can.
That who's the person that advises you
on like nutrition because they're a guy,
um,
who told,
taught you how to do it?
How do you do it?
Well,
there's a ton of people that I've used
as a resource.
Um,
there's a woman that I have on the
podcast on a regular basis.
Her name is Doctor Rhonda Patrick and
she's probably the best resource.
Like I sent her something the other day
on some new,
um,
some new study on saturated fats.
Like whenever I,
there's some sort of an issue,
there's some new study on cryotherapy or
Saunas.
Saunas are incredibly effective.
I don't know if you ever just gone,
oh,
so the UV rays or what is it?
The,
um,
what is it called?
Not Ultra violent.
Um,
infrared.
They'd be ready.
Yeah,
we just got one of those Saunas are
giant,
you know,
the raising of the body temperature like
that,
and a heat shock proteins,
incredibly beneficial to your body.
There was a study that they put out
recently that showed a 40% decrease in
mortality from all causes due to people
who take regular sauna.
Like it just literally keeps your body
healthier.
Wow.
Having that massive exposure to heat and
the your body producing these heat shock
proteins,
it just,
it,
it reduces inflammation.
It just,
it helps in so many different areas for
people and it's just,
you know,
sit down in the hot room.
It's really good for your body.
Regular is how many times a week?
Um,
for Sauna,
I think they were saying four times a
week.
But I mean how hard is that man just
force yourself to sit in it?
I mean if you have it at home and in
particular at your gym,
just go there and sit in that fucker for
15 minutes.
It doesn't take long.
Well,
I mean I have to get all this written
up.
I'm going to,
how about this?
I do everything you do.
We make that a special,
it's the judd does Joe's programs.
He's have to heal up the bulk up.
Well,
I may have already bulked up build up
like your joints and all that stuff.
It's got to get used to that kind of a
pounding.
Yeah,
there's a lot.
A lot of shit is going to be happening
if you want to do everything I do.
So I can't just do 12 pounds on a
freeway.
You just,
you don't want,
I mean it's not even,
you don't,
you're not going to want to do
everything I do.
Like I have a friend who runs ultra
marathons and I just started running
recently within the last couple months.
I'm not running a fucking ultra
marathon.
I'm not doing everything.
He,
I'll do everything you do.
I would break.
It would break my feet,
my knees.
Yeah.
You got to just build up.
You gotta have time to,
yes.
There's something about,
you know when you run a TV shows,
it's all freaking day everyday.
So people will say,
when do you work out?
I'm like,
there's no time.
What am I going to wake up at in the
morning and put in two and a half hours?
I,
I drive my kids to school at seven 40.
That's one thing.
You don't need two and a half hours.
Yeah.
You could get a great workout in,
in 40 minutes and that's all you need
for the whole day.
100%.
You really can't,
especially if you run like I run hills
and I can get it done in a half an hour,
like a fucking brutal workout,
a two mile brutal hill climbing workout
in half hour,
I'm exhausted.
Yeah.
You know,
this idea of time,
like how much time did you put in today?
Like you could work out in a bullshit
manner for two hours and not get nearly
as much done as you can for a half hour.
Hard just running.
Yeah.
We're like interval training.
Sprints and then relax.
Then sprints again.
But uh,
I just think being active and doing
something on a daily basis,
forcing your body to get used to the
fact that it's going to constantly
being,
be working constantly being under
stress,
and then it just,
it gives you more energy.
It's like you have more of a gas tank,
you have more enthusiasm for things.
That's the scary part about trump.
His theory on exercises.
You only have so much energy per day and
he thinks that exercise uses it up.
Yeah.
And so he doesn't ever exercise.
That's got to come back out of it
someplace.
Just fucking 70 I mean how was it?
And I come back at him already,
but he also,
I mean he's,
he's not mitigating it stress.
That's part of it.
Is Your perspective enhancing?
For me the most important thing about,
I don't think maybe they're not the most
important thing.
One of the best things about exercise is
that it gives me a perspective,
a better,
a more enhanced perspective.
Cause I know I'm not coming at it from a
stressful body.
Like my body is not tense so I can come
at things in a calm way.
I've drained all the bullshit out of my
budget thing.
Yeah.
And Are you doing meditation or what are
you doing in that way?
I have a sensory deprivation tank.
Yeah.
So I do most of my meditation in that
you do an ultra climb and yeah,
a climate and I float.
Yeah,
I love that.
That's one of my favorite things that
you ever do it?
Uh,
no I couldn't imagine you must
especially for you because you're
working on things all the time.
Like if you go in there with an idea
like I'll go in there with a bit like I
got this bit that I'm working on right
now,
that's kind of complicated and sometimes
we'll just be sitting there staring at
the wall.
Just thinking about this one bit because
I'm trying to figure out how to,
how to structure it.
It's just super complicated bit and I'll
go in that tank and I'll just sit there
for an hour and I'll just try to work
out this bit and tried to figure out if
there are other angles to it is other
ways to come at it.
The only confusing thing is when I have
an idea in the tank and it seems like I
got it,
I got to get out of the tank and then I
got to write things down.
And you need a special pad and the pen.
I think I need a voice activated
recorder.
I think that's a good idea.
Yeah,
I think that's what I need.
Where I can just talk.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I need the tank.
You need to have the spa.
You have a spa.
Um,
I need a hill to run on hills are good.
I got,
I need more of my audit products.
Do you lift weights at all?
Uh,
no.
I good idea to do a little bit of
something just to keep your body strong.
It's like as you get older,
your body atrophies and
there's just no way around it.
Especially if you're not using it.
And the only way to keep it from
atrophying is to make sure that you put
it under stress.
You have to lift weights.
It's the only way it keeps your bone
density,
keeps your tendon strength,
your muscle strength.
There's no other way,
you know,
and otherwise he's got injuries.
People get back into reason.
Arm injuries and shit just starts
falling apart on,
you.
See,
I've had no injuries due to not doing
anything.
That's how I've been protecting by my
body.
But yes,
I do know that that's the thing to do.
I remember I always heard about Clint
Eastwood doing that and I met Clint
Eastwood when he was like 80.
And I know he's like,
he lifts heavyweights.
That's his thing.
It's like heavyweights.
And he was a truck at 80.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
but I don't like,
lifting things.
I don't even like counting,
counting hire a trainer.
Yeah.
You know,
get someone to devise a program.
Yeah.
Have them come to you,
work you out.
You don't have to do shit.
You just show up.
You know,
like you could do it in your house.
They show up at 6:00 AM or whenever it
is and like,
come on John,
I got you for the next 45 minutes and
you're like,
all right,
here we go.
And just make,
when you hate that stuff really is tough
when you haven't built your brain to
love it.
I've been playing a lot of tennis lately
as a way to great wake up and uh,
but I do know that I need to do it,
but man,
it is when you're like of the mindset
that when the trainer comes,
you want to punch him in the face.
It's a tough,
it's a tough thing.
I know a lot of it is being a writer.
Your,
your day becomes about waking up and
engaging your brain all day.
And so you just like look at writers and
eat Chinese food and you're kicking
stuff around and it's like developing
the wrong muscle your whole life or at
least not only one muscle.
And uh,
I know that I have to transition into
that,
but it is,
it is a tough one to one.
I stopped,
I official to your writing.
Now it is,
it 100% is I write better after I do
anything.
And what I do do is I walk really fast
around my neighborhood in circles for
like 45 minutes every day.
They say,
you should do that after you're right.
They say when you ride,
one of the things you should do is go
over what you wrote by going on a walk
because it's not enough where you're so
worn out that you're occupied by the,
like,
it's not like you're running or you're
exhausted.
You're occupied by the activity.
Cause I feel like when I'm running hard,
especially when I do my hill sprints,
I'm not thinking about shit other than
left foot.
Right foot,
left foot,
right foot.
Don't fall down,
keep going.
We're almost at the hill,
almost at the top.
Keep going,
keep going,
keep going.
I don't wanna thinking about anything
else,
but when I walk I can think about all
kinds of shit.
So I walk my dog around the neighborhood
a lot of times after that.
Right.
Just take him.
We'll go for a walk.
And that's like a walking meditation.
Yeah.
Cause I'm,
I'm trying to read a lot like,
and you guys talk about it sometimes.
I heard you talking about with Russell
brand,
just,
you know,
quantum physics and trying to figure out
how to quiet my brain and to tune into
what is left to
do,
to not be crazy.
And some of that is exercise because
left to do,
to not be crazy.
Exactly.
Cause I was such a like a such a pop
psychology junkie.
Yeah.
I read that stuff all day long.
But lately I've been reading a little
more like the,
you know,
the Joe Dispenza,
is that his name?
Joe Dispenza.
Yeah.
But it's,
you know,
it's just,
it's,
it's a cook quantum physics theory that
basically you get into a pattern of how
you feel and it's in yourself.
So if you're a depressed person,
like yourselves are depressed and if you
get in a good mood,
your cells try to get you back to
depression because you've conditioned
yourself to be in a certain mood all the
time physically and it affects your
whole body and that you can make a
choice to change how you are physically
by choosing to be in a certain mood and
meditating about a certain mood and that
you could change how your body reacts
physically.
So it doesn't want to keep you in the
same mental state you're used to being
in.
Does that make any sense?
It does sort of,
I guess I'm always real cautious about
what,
what causes depression and what makes
people depressed and what,
you know,
I don't,
I don't suffer from depression,
so like whenever someone says you're
depressed because of this,
I'm always like,
hmm,
okay.
I don't know how to address that because
I don't know what,
I know there's certain people that do
have absolute chemical imbalances,
but what does that chemical imbalance
come from?
Does it come from childhood trauma?
Does it come from just some sort of a
part of their body that's not
functioning correctly,
like a bad thyroid or a bad kidney?
Is the brain like very similar?
Is that the case or are they in a bad
economic situation?
In a bad relationship with bad friends
and a bad job?
Is that what's causing depression?
Like I think there's a host of
variables.
Yeah,
it's a,
you get an a pattern.
You don't know.
You don't know why.
I mean your family to do your parents.
Uh,
did they stay together?
No.
Yeah.
So you
step ma or my stepdad rather,
and my mom had been together since I was
seven.
Yeah.
So you had the stable.
Yes.
Yeah.
And I think that's,
I always think that's 90% of it.
When you grow up in chaos,
I think you get wired for a certain
hyper vigilance and,
and nervousness and anxiety because you
think like more bad shit's coming.
Yeah.
So if you had any kind of trauma as a
kid,
I think you're wired to keep your eyes
open a little wider,
which also lends itself to some kind of
depression.
It could,
most certainly for me,
uh,
that hypervigilance led itself to
martial arts.
Yeah.
And then it's also,
we moved around a lot,
so I was picked on a lot,
so I was like,
I was always the new kid.
I was like,
God,
this fucking sucks,
you know?
So that,
that sort of led me to be wary of others
and just,
you know,
be internalize a lot of stuff.
Sure.
Um,
I think I,
that's what I did.
I just went in my room and watch the
Mike Douglas show and watch Merv
Griffin.
Did you know,
you knew,
so that from the time you were 17,
you were working at East side comedy
club,
you kind of knew you always wanted to be
involved in common.
From the time I was 10,
I was into the Marx brothers first,
then like cosby and George Carlin and,
uh,
I used to listen to lenny bruce records
as a kid.
I didn't understand them,
but I just heard that's the best person.
And I always,
I think I liked that comedians just
called out bullshit.
And I must have felt like there was a
lot of bullshit around me because I
liked the and called.
Yeah,
I liked that.
It was like George Carlin was like,
no,
this makes no fucking sense.
And so I love those people.
And,
and,
and the lighter stuff too,
like just silly comedians who just
pointed out the ridiculousness of
things.
So I loved Seinfeld when I was a kid
and,
and Leno,
but especially Carlin,
I think when I was little,
well Groucho Marx is pretty underrated
and under appreciated to this day.
Like my roommate,
he was hosting that show you bet your
life.
Oh,
absolutely.
So funny and so dirty and weird people
like,
and,
and even like when you watch them and be
like,
duck soup,
the Marx brothers movie,
it's all about the ridiculousness of
government.
And uh,
and something drew me to those people.
I think it was also because I was bad at
sports and so I thought this system's
unfair.
Like,
so I'm a Dick because I can't play
softball.
So it led me to like look for something
else.
But back then,
no one else likes comedy.
There wasn't another person to talk to
about it.
Now I think everyone likes it.
But back then there was no one was
watching Merv Griffin but me really when
I was little,
I mean it,
when I was 15 I didn't like come to
school and we would laugh about Jeff
Altman on Merv Griffin.
I was just alone with it.
Wow.
Yeah.
I became a fan of a standup watching
standup on TV,
like watching like the tonight show and
evening at the Improv and stuff like
that.
But really the big one,
the run that really kicked in for me was
my parents took me to see live on the
sunset strip.
Oh Wow.
And I was a teenager,
young teenager.
And uh,
I remember being in the audience while
Richard Pryor was onstage slaying and
people were laughing so hard and I was
laughing so hard.
I looked around,
I'll never forget this moment cause I
looked around at the crowd while the
movie was going on and all these people
were like falling out of their chairs
after their knee holding her chest.
And I was like,
this guy's just talking.
He's just talking.
And he's this funny,
this is incredible.
I'm like,
this is an amazing thing this guy can do
like I'd never seen real standup before.
I had only seen like,
you know,
like someone on the Johnny Carson show
do a couple minutes and tell a few
jokes.
That in my mind was what stand up was.
It wasn't until,
and I had listened to some of the old
bill cosby stuff and some of the old
Carlin stuff on,
on uh,
records,
but I'd never seen it like seeing the
movie live on the sunset strip and that
planted didn't plant a seed.
Like I can do it,
but it did plant a seed.
Like Holy Shit,
this is possible.
Like this is crazy that this is
possible.
It's still the best special.
It's one of the best ever.
Without a doubt.
He's still,
he holds up in a,
in a very,
very unique way where a lot of comedy
from that era just immune including
lenny bruce doesn't really hold up like
gets caught be.
It's because it's contextual.
Like if you were there in that time,
it was groundbreaking,
but that's not groundbreaking anymore
because the culture has moved on so far.
And a lot of that could be attributed to
his insight like Lenny Bruce incite
change the way a lot of people thought
and discussed a lot of like really
important issues at that time.
But there was something about priors,
his honesty and his,
his delivery and his point of view
that's like to this day like God,
he was good.
I,
there was a record they put out a few
years ago where they didn't tell you
what album it was,
but it was just bits and I think maybe a
lot of,
of of bits that were recorded when he
recorded an album but didn't make the
album.
Like it was just,
it was,
uh,
an eras like seventies,
80s,
90s.
And when you listen to his stuff from
the 70s,
it's so militant.
Yeah.
It's so milton and it all works
perfectly today.
Like what he's mad about.
Yeah,
all applies to right now.
And then when he goes honest about
himself and relationships,
you do feel it.
Like,
oh,
there's not many people opening it up
like this.
Right.
Like there's not a comparable person.
There's a lot of comedians who talk
about their lives,
but he's really,
he's ripping open the,
the veins much deeper than anybody even
now.
Sure.
And he was talking about horrific
addiction issues that he had back then.
I mean,
addiction issues that caused them to
light himself on fire.
Yeah.
I mean when he was talking about that
back then,
who the hell had done that?
You remember he would do that thing.
We would light a match and,
and move it around.
Like what,
who am I?
I'm Richard Pryor running down the
street and joke around about lighting
himself on fire and,
and have the whole audience laugh.
It was like,
wow.
It was crazy.
There was some bits where he talked
about having multiple sclerosis near the
end of his life and he was still doing
the comedy store and on audio they were
riot asleep.
Funny,
brutally honest bits about,
you know,
what it felt like to be that sick.
And I don't think it ever was on an
album before when he was doing that.
Um,
when he was,
uh,
coming back to the comedy store when he
was really sick before he died,
I was the guy who went on after him
every night,
every night for like five weeks.
So Geez,
every time he did his show,
I bombed so many times going on after
Richard Pryor.
Oh,
it was death.
And how was he terrible?
He was,
he was old and he was sick and he was
drunk and he was on pills and he
probably shouldn't have been there,
but he just wanted to do it.
It wasn't good.
Like it wasn't,
it wasn't Richard Pryor.
It was like they had it,
first of all,
he was really unhealthy so they had to
crank the microphone up.
Like
you couldn't even hear Shira
barely hear him and you know,
he would like,
I always love pussy.
Like it wasn't,
there was nothing there.
Yeah,
he was just kind of talking and ranting
and he would,
you know,
he'd be on stage with a drink and people
didn't know how to respond and they
would give him this amazing round of
applause when he got on stage.
And it took forever for them to get them
to the stage because chewy who worked
the door and this guy dave,
um,
would carry Richard prior to the stage
and slowly just move him towards the
stage and all the time that people would
be clapping and then they would sit him
down and then they would put the
microphone in place and crank that
fucking thing up to 10 and then he would
do is stand up.
But it was,
it was people almost like paying all
much Omaj the paying homage.
They were there,
they were there to see the great one,
you know,
when he was there and he's still alive
and it's like,
wow,
we're seeing like the greatest standup
comedian of all time.
He's right there.
Wow.
You know,
it was more of that than it was like him
doing really well.
It was never like a good set.
I never saw him kill.
And then you would come out,
how was he eat dick just go up there and
just eat plates of Shit.
People were so depressed.
So way on.
What was your attempt to uh,
to pull out of it?
Um,
I would go on stage and I would say,
and now ladies and gentlemen and unknown
White Guy after the greatest comedians
of all time,
this douchey looking Italian looking
kid,
I would just make fun of myself for a
few minutes and you know,
and then sometimes
about how,
uh,
Richard Pryor was like,
you know,
cause I would take a long time for him
to get off the stage too.
So that was the other thing.
Like I would get introduced by Jeff
who's a piano man and I would pass
Richard and Dave and Chewy as they were
carrying Richard off.
Like you'd have to kind of move around
them and then get onto the stage and
then you'd have to say,
Richard Pryor,
ladies and gentlemen,
give it,
and sometimes ppc people's eyes,
they were like,
fuck,
like,
what did we just see?
Like this is so to facing their own
mortality.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
And you know Richard,
like I remember like he wasn't supposed
to drink but he drank anyway cause they
had them on all this medication and
you're like fuck you just kept drinking.
It was weird.
It was,
it was dark.
I remember meeting him at a birthday
party.
I went with Jim character to his
birthday party and it was,
it was sad.
I mean it was,
it was sad to see but somebody that ill
and then especially when you think of
just the power of the guy,
just how crazy funny he was.
Cause there's not that many people just
took the core funny.
They,
I remember when Robin Williams,
we used to come into the Improv in the
late eighties and he would kill so hard.
There was just no way to recover the
room couldn't recover.
Yeah.
And there's not that many people can do
that now.
I feel like people could follow each
other now.
You know Louie comes in and you go on
after him and you know and,
and like he kills.
But like Robin Williams would come in
like you wanted to end the show,
right?
Well,
there was only one of him then,
you know,
and now there's like Louis,
but then there's bird and then there's
Diaz and then there's,
there's a lot of guys now,
there's Santino and Ari Shaffir and this
like,
there's so many funny people now maybe
the audience understands in a different
way and they can transition.
They,
they're,
they're used to comedy and they're like,
oh,
now this guy where the old days you'd
come on and there's,
you know,
they couldn't go and,
oh,
we're about to enjoy this,
this popery of people.
Right.
Well,
she's still see people bomb after
someone who kills.
Yeah.
Still,
that's still happens all the time.
But I think that,
um,
maybe I was more,
I think what you're getting at the store
now,
and this is what's been really
interesting lately,
is you're getting a lot of comedy
tourism.
Yeah.
Like a lot of people fly over from
Europe just to come to the store all in
lot a lot.
And it's worth it.
Those lineups are crazy.
Some night.
Oh yeah.
Like,
I'll look at the lineup and go,
does this audience understand how insane
this is?
Yeah,
yeah.
And there's three shows going on
simultaneously.
There's a belly room,
the original room in the main room and
everyone,
and you know a lot of guys do hat
tricks.
Well,
they'll do all three rooms and one night
the seller's like that,
the comedy cellar in New York,
there's three rooms and you go in some
nights and it's like,
yeah.
Chappelle's come in.
Rock just left like really tonight?
Yeah.
Schumer's here.
There's only a few of those places I had
to follow Andrew Dice Clay and Ray
Romano,
the seller.
Once it was like the cleanest guy and
the dirtiest guy.
Do you know I had the worst sets after
ever ways it could not follow Martin
Lawrence.
Oh yeah.
Martin Lawrence in the 90s sure.
I remembered Chris Rock says that Martin
Lawrence was opening up for him in the
90s,
uh,
or,
or you know,
before he did his big specials and that
he was downstairs in the dressing room
and he could feel the theater rocking.
And he went on stage and he said he had
had some shows where he couldn't follow
him the way he wanted to and that's what
made him work hard and then develop
those great specials because having
Martin opened for him scared him.
Yeah.
Well he also said that he did too many
crowds in front of white people.
Yeah.
Too many shows in front of white crowds
and they were just too,
too happy and too,
except day and Martin Lawrence or just
bring the thunder dude.
He was so strong before he put the
wetsuit on and ran around with a gun in
the middle of the city and the in the
heat,
like a whatever fuse he blew.
But before that,
that fucking guy would go onstage with a
leather jumpsuit on and just destroyed.
I mean destroy in a level that people
don't appreciate today.
People forgot about him.
Everything.
Gary Owen.
Yes,
I was as hell.
It's a two in a set.
I was playing Bonnaroo and biff.
I wanted to go on the night before to
warm up and I went to xannies and
Nashville and he's there and I hadn't
seen him before and I did
a set and uh,
you know,
it was okay.
It wasn't very good.
It was just fine.
And then he gets on.
I don't,
I've never heard louder left.
I've never heard louder last me and my
manager,
Jimmy Miller sat in the back of the room
and we were like,
what is happening?
And then we start really paying
attention going,
how funny is this guy?
Like,
like listening to the material?
Like is this good material or is he
pandering or what is it?
Then we're like,
wait a second,
here's the materials.
Incredible.
Like he is awesome.
And it was the biggest labs I've ever
heard.
He had a sustained like killing the
crowd,
you know,
where the place is just rocking and
moving up and down.
It's just a lot of black shows,
right?
Yes.
And uh,
he went full 20,
25 minutes at 10 before he slowed it
down and had to slow it down and he was
going to kill these people.
And I swear I thought,
I don't know if I'm in the same
businesses,
this guy like,
is this what we're supposed to do?
Well when you,
when you jumped back into it,
you thought that three years ago you're
just going to have some fun and go and
do it.
When was it that you realize like I am a
comic now,
I've got a kind of like really aspire to
a high standard,
like I have to really tighten everything
up.
I think,
um,
you know,
I would,
I was watching Louie work on his new set
very seriously at the comedy cellar and
he'd say,
yeah,
I got nothing.
I got nothing tonight and go onstage and
just crush.
And then I played Carnegie Hall and I
had a good set for the New York comedy
festival.
And then as a surprise,
I brought sandler out to do a surprise
set after me and I thought I did great.
And then when he came out the,
the laughter went up 20% where I felt it
like,
oh,
I'm like at a seven and he's at a nine
and a half.
Like it was a diff,
the sound changed and I thought,
oh,
there's a whole nother step here that I
need to kick into gear.
I always want the material to be good,
but that,
oh,
there's a a way to crush that's hard to
do,
to get that momentum and have the ideas.
And obviously Chris Rock is one of the
best of everybody at it because he has
so many great ideas,
but understands how to get the room rock
and really hard.
The cadence and the peace and the,
and to find what,
what is in your cadence that does it,
that doesn't become obnoxious or loud or
just,
you know,
just talking fast.
Like how do you find an original way to
create that energy in a room?
I think the only way it's constant
repetition.
You have to be on stage all the time.
Yeah.
And you have to really always be trying
to improve it and you have to always be
listening to your recordings and you
have to have,
and you've got to listen to bad sets.
Two sets go bad.
You got to go,
why didn't that go back?
And let's listen to this fucking thing.
I always hear myself mumble like,
oh,
they didn't even hear what I said.
That's big.
I got to stumble.
Well,
I gotta get Outta here.
I gotta go pick up a child.
Oh,
I'm going to do my end of the show.
Plage he'll drink.
I got
the big sick.
Get a website,
dude.
Okay.
I squarespace website.
So you're saying there's a place called
squarespace that has websites.
I've heard about this can make your own
website.
Okay.
I'm at the Wilbur on the 24th in Boston.
July 24th 23rd richfield play house in
Connecticut and the 25th canceling
Canetti Columbus Theater.
Providence,
Rhode Island,
Connecticut.
Higgs.
Why is that?
I always do,
which is for the hat of the work in
Connecticut.
I'm not kidding.
It's not a real estate.
Okay,
I'm going to die.
I'm going to figure that out to highway
between Boston and New York.
I'm gonna let you know if that's true.
Don't do it.
But as of now,
talk later after that you're like,
oh my God,
you were so right that Connecticut Gig
was horrible.
I need Connecticut people to show me
he's wrong.
All these Connecticut people are mad at
me now.
I get emails from connect it,
Bro.
How about Leo Fucking Connecticut?
How about drive to Boston or drive from
New York and recognize the fuck you
doing
John Appetite.
Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you for having me.
Thanks for being here,
man.
That's it for the week.
Good night,
ladies and gentlemen.
Yeah.